Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Sorry for the late start.
I like woke up like an hour ago and then I had so many
messages.
It's like crunch hours right now for a bunch.
A lot of stuff.
Give me a second.
Oh my god!
Sorry, we're messages.
Uh...
Anyway, guys, I heard the game got delayed because of
lightning, but we all know it got delayed because I didn't
start my stream on time
That what game is delayed for and they're like she's not
here yet guys stop Guys we gotta stop the game.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry World Cup.
Don't worry.
I'm here now And they're like, where did she go?
Where did she stop?
Stop the game.
We can't start until Doki's streaming.
Yeah, they have to wait for the VIP right now.
Don't worry, the very important person is here now.
The Doki rigged the game.
It was you.
Honorary Mexican reporting for duty.
one of my uh mexican friends sent me this music you have to
play this on stream and i was like i'm not i'm not getting
dcma bro but like he's like you gotta play this song on
stream all right guys i'm gonna order mexican food since we
have an hour before have they even sang the national anthems
yet uh
Have they Have they sang the national anthems, guys?
Or like Put on the music?
No, they haven't.
Is it actually delayed for an hour?
Oh, is it like hard raining right now?
Alright, guys.
Suggest me some Mexican...
I haven't eaten at all today.
I've been like working...
slept way too much yesterday um so unfortunately i do not
have a green white and red uh skin suit uh this is actually
technically i do technically i do have a green white and red
skin suit but i i i'm worried it might come off as racist to
be a tomato cheering for mexico so i
yeah I might look a little bad it might why I don't I don't
want to I don't want to risk it unless my fellow Mexicans
like give me the approval to be a tomato I I don't know I
don't know why I just I just know I was like why your tomato
and then they're like oh it's because I'm just, I don't
think people, we give her the password today.
I just, I'm just, I'm just paranoid, okay?
I was like, why am I a fruit cheering for Mexico?
I was just like, you get the password, you get the hat too.
All right.
All right, all right, let's go, okay.
Let me, let me pull it up real quick, guys.
That's the only skin suit I have.
That's red, white, and green.
It's the only one in there.
All right.
I don't remember what hats I have.
Let me check.
What do I have?
I'm just like, I have a cowboy hat.
Is that?
But if I wear the cowboy hat, it's going to cover the only
green I have.
Can't toggle it on, guys.
That's the only green I have.
All right, we're gonna...
There we go.
Vamos, Mexico.
Oh, Smokey, thank you for the magenta soup, but thank you,
thank you.
All right, let's go.
I'm sorry, Ecuador.
I'm so sorry.
Make it a very tiny cowboy.
give me the speedy Gonzalez vibes my true form um I'm gonna
say I'm sorry Ecuador but um a nice old a nice well she
wasn't old a nice mature lady came up to me and while long
story short I was in a restaurant where there was a it was
just all Mexicans um because the Canada Switzerland game
right after was the Mexico game um well not right after but
it was like in like the game um the game after Korea I think
was it anyway no it wasn't after Korea it was just something
there was a game in between between Canada versus
Switzerland and then Mexico versus something else um so
someone else and then sorry I know there's a Switzerland
flag below me uh but this is a picture from when I was there
and so it was just me the only person there and then
everyone was Mexican and then uh and then I was confused
because I didn't realize they were all Mexican um uh because
I didn't know what the jerseys were uh and then like they
were drinking a Mexican drink and I wanted and I but I
didn't realize it was a Mexican shot like specifically for
them because I asked the waiter if I could have one too
because I was like wait everyone's drinking it I want to be
included I was just like, what is everyone, wait a minute, I
want to be included.
Can I also have one too?
And then the waiter was like, no, it's not for you.
Like, you're like, we can't make you this.
Because they could tell I'm not Mexican, I guess.
I don't know how they could tell.
And then, you know, while they were all eating, like, we
were all eating.
And yeah, I had FOMO.
And then this nice mature lady who was sitting next to me
was like, oh, are you Mexican?
And I was like, no, I just came back from Canada versus
Switzerland game.
And she's like, you're an honorary Mexican now.
And she's like, salute.
And then everyone else in the restaurant was like, salute.
And I was like, salute.
So anyway.
Anyway, now I'm here to cheer for.
Now I'm here to cheer for Mexico.
Shout out to that nice lady that made me an honorary
Mexican.
Ooh, salo!
Um, I'm sorry, Ecuador.
But if, if Mexico loses, I would like to do a disclaimer.
It's not because of me, guys.
I didn't get the drink.
the drink so i just salute with my uh i think it was like a
non-alcoholic cocktail concoction i don't fucking know what
i was drinking i already forgot what it was called uh guys i
just need you guys know disclaimer just just a heads up if
for some reason if uh mexico loses it's not my fault
It's someone else's fault, guys.
It's not me.
It's someone else I was watching.
Okay, guys.
It's not me, guys.
Please do not dox me.
Please lower your pitchforks, everybody.
Guys, guys, it's not me, guys.
Don't look.
Don't come to, don't find me.
It's not why you put the energy out there.
Just so you guys, just if in a possible event happens, What
happens?
Right?
Shut up.
You're not kidding.
As the Mexican you get the pass, the word.
A tomato seed, signora.
Don't keep on stars.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Matrix, they give a super chat.
Honorary Mexican.
Let's fucking go.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're my prima now, Doki.
Uh, Edo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki is very Mexican.
It puts on barrels and mustaches.
Our favorite anime characters.
We love that.
I'll put the mustache.
This.
Oh, shit.
Sorry.
I'll put the mustache on.
I just, guys, if we put on a hat, it covers the only green I
have.
Oh, they're going on the field.
It's not delayed.
That, oh, never mind.
Count on to kick off.
Fucking one.
Just because I started my stream.
stream that's my bad guys that's oh this is norway versus
avarico so yeah i heard about i heard holland um did a crazy
ass goal at the end uh all right i'm so sorry guys i'm so
sorry i i'm sorry didn't come here in time i didn't know
they would delay the game for me i didn't know they were
panicking wondering why i didn't sign my stream yet so they
have to delay the game game.
I'm... That's my bad, everyone.
I'm so sorry, guys.
Damn.
Alright, let me... Apparently there's lightning because God
was like, where's Doki Bird?
He got angry, so he's like, do not start until Doki goes
live.
Until my favorite VTuber goes live.
Coincidence that the lightning stopped after I went live?
Hmm.
God was mad.
All right, let's get up.
Can't do this without Doki watching.
Exactly.
All right, let me...
It's so true.
No Doki, no game.
All right, what kind of mustache do you guys want?
Make sure I don't get cancelled
Guys we're towing a fine line right now, so we're trying I
didn't need I'll let you guys pick a mustache
All right
All right, let's see
Just put the mustache and hat on.
I'm not going to put a hat.
It's going to cover the only green I have.
I'll do the mustache.
Queenie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
If Mexico loses, we're turning you.
Please don't turn me into salsa.
Do not turn me into salsa, please.
Make the hat.
Just get a green sombrero.
Is there a green sombrero?
I just see it.
Oh, there is.
Yeah, but it doesn't.
There's no PNGs of it.
Mustache or PNG.
Is this?
Is this good enough?
If I use this, it's so...
Oh, this is good enough.
All right, guys.
Mexico 26.
I'm sorry, I don't know how to speak Spanish.
I'm sorry.
I don't know how to speak Spanish.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh, so I don't know why I put it out.
I was like a Francia Spanish.
Uh, some.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
El sombrero stays on.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, solid.
All right, let me grab.
Um, let me grab my mustache.
Did I download it?
You wouldn't download a mustache off the internet, would
you?
What?
No, not.
I didn't say spinach.
I said, like, it's like an, I put like, for some reason, I
went like, spanish as in, like, when I say frondage.
like France so I don't know why like my tongue just slipped
there uh AZ thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you
okay I'm glad I finally catch a stream as I graduate from my
basic combat training and now I'm I'm in advanced training a
place kinder to the soul mind and body but those four months
of hell uh made me a stronger dragon so have some tax paper
payers money vamos mexico yeah thank you the alcazupa thank
you thank you congratulations oh is this when holland scored
oh yeah that is oh yeah his dad started crying because he's
like a pro player too and it's been the first time they it's
been like how many years 28 years or some shit since they um
since they've like oh my god that wasn't he's like poop I
didn't even see he's like What the fuck was that That's like
the most anti-climatic Like shot ever That's since 98 Yeah
20 plus years That's sad I feel like the goalie Oh my god
Don't turn it It sucks to turn it into Pico Tagalog Thank
you for the super chat Pawns sorry thank you thank you again
for the Thank you.
Thank you.
Spontaneous.
Super chat.
Oh, they're very, they're, they're, they're very sad.
Neppers.
Thank you.
The super chat.
A white headband might work.
It adds more white and sort of separates the red and the
green.
Thank you.
The super chat.
Neppers.
Thank you.
Papa Smurf.
They give us super chat.
Thank you.
I'm sorry, guys.
It's because I didn't show up on time and God got worried.
They're like, where does she go?
this this is a part of history yeah and and then boom
lightning strike uh i'm watching from uh ts tsn right now
the only legal legal very legal i paid a i paid it oh i like
the interview where we're like do you think you're gonna uh
do you think they're gonna beat brazil and he's like no
like yeah I'm watching uh yeah I'm watching from the TSN
which is like the only site you can watch in Canada to why
what why is he wearing a cowboy I already paid a
subscription fee I might as well good thing I'm doing this
watch along because I already paid the fucking subscription
fee to watch this um i literally i unsubscribed a crave for
so fucking long and i finally resubscribed for this day uh
what was it oh yeah my mustache mustache okay let me let me
do my mustache real quick uh it's a very okay the mustache
might be like super realistic all right give me a sec let me
let me grow a mustache real quick guys um All right, give me
a sec.
Let me grow my mustache.
Where the fuck did I save it?
Guys, it's so easy, girl.
Well, you can't...
What?
You can't...
You can't grow a mustache, guys.
It's so easy.
Watch this.
Okay.
Guys.
You can't grow a mustache.
this guys oh shit
there we go give me a sec I'm trying to attach it
I said okay good let's make it tiny let's just make it let's
just make it tiny okay
Okay, wait, we're having a little issue here with my
mustache.
There we go.
Doesn't it look so bad.
It's perfect.
I'm trying my best.
This must...
Okay, wait, wait.
Let me...
There we go.
Is that...
No, that's not better.
My immersion...
It's a little...
Is this bad?
Okay, let's... Oh, he got closer.
Why are you mad?
Okay, that's better.
That's better.
Alright.
Why are you mad?
You had food!
Food!
Alright.
Do we want...
What kind of hat do you want me to wear, guys?
What kind of...
He wants some...
A stash tail.
He got jealous.
Yeah.
Jealous of my beautiful mustache.
He doesn't recognize me.
What?
No.
Why?
Go.
All right.
I don't know why.
He got really jealous of my mustache.
A sombrero.
All right.
It has to be a green sombrero.
though because okay png it has to be a green one wait it's
it has to be a really tiny sombrero it's my mustache i'm
trying this is not a good enough mustache oh it took a
really long time to grow it has to be a very tiny hat by the
way that's a really fucking tiny I can't let it hide the
only green I have.
It's literally the only green I have.
Alright, sombrero.
And then, transparent.
Alright.
Does this sombrero work?
I don't know.
Does this one work?
Is this...
I'm towing a fine line right now.
I'm towing a very fine line right now, so I need to be very
careful with what I pick.
Let's see.
Don't stress whatever you do.
Never repeat anything we chat during the game or you will be
canceled.
Star, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
He got PNG of Kagama, please.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What's up, Kagama?
Oh!
Okay, sure.
I'll give you a I'll give you a PNG of that.
Alright.
Sure.
PNG.
Does this work, guys?
Oh, my gosh.
This is not even transparent.
What the fuck?
Like,
Okay.
All right.
Transparent.
Is this transparent?
Is it this?
All right.
I'm just hearing Mbappe.
Apparently he did like a salute too.
When he scored after and people were like, he can't believe
he did that.
All right.
Let me add it in.
Let's see, I'll put it here, and then items, and then I
haven't even ordered food.
At this rate, I should have ordered food before I do all of
this.
Okay, wait, I'm trying to...
There we go.
Is this good, guys?
Is this...
Is this good?
Am I immersed now?
She's Mexican.
Is this what?
Am I?
Do I?
Yeah.
That's what I'm talking about.
Am I?
Am I immersive now?
Yes.
She's just like my dad.
Welcome.
Hello.
I am I am a new dokey from the dokeyverse.
I am Mexican dokey now now to actually trick her with a beer
IRL.
Are you cosplaying my dad?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is the newest dokey from the dokeyverse.
I'm I'm practically salsa.
I see a cancel.
Wait, I thought I got the I thought Angel, thank you for
that super chat, thank you, thank you Poppy, is that you?
No!
I didn't have the path!
I'm practically salsa, that's how Mexican I am now.
Let's see.
Doki Dolores bird, you became a complete Mexican so
suddenly, Joel, they give us a super chat, thank you, thank
you, but Donald, Tokyo, and Sax, they give us a super chat,
thank you, thank you, thank you, damn, why does Tokyo look
like my Mexican uncle?
I am, my uncle's a YouTuber, that's right, that's how you're
gonna, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, son, that's how you're gonna
find out.
Uh, what is?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yo, Crero, Dokey Bird.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Maddie, thank you.
Welcome to the Dokeyverse and Salsa Bird.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You guys think I still need my sombrero?
You think I still need a sombrero?
Guys, I'm still trying to find a sombrero right now.
Or do you think that's enough?
the snacks wait what kind of snacks do you guys want i'm
sorry if i had to find out this way miho it would complete
the look all right what do you want what kind of snacks do
you want yeah how do you say uncle uncle and mixed in uh
spanish tio what would you like your tio to get you a card
what would you like a teo to get you i'm i have one more
hand i can grab you snacks
oh sombrero mirachi mirachi okay
we're already still taught oh they're talking about the
france game oh my god there's so many guys all right we'll
have a vote we'll have a vote for the snacks what kind of
snack do you want your teal to get you
all right i see nachos taco taco uh what else what else
takis
Sabri tons All right I'm going to replace Okay, I'm going to
corn Okay, I'm replacing Takis with corn Guys All right,
vote for your favorite snack That you want your deal to get
you Don't worry, we have Still have 36 minutes to kick off
But he's still up in 36 of minutes, so it'll be a while,
guys.
It's gonna be a while.
I could practically have food for us right now.
All right, let's see.
I'm still trying to find a hat.
A very tiny hat.
All right.
Let's see.
Is this transparent?
This is like the closest I could find.
Like, trans...
I feel like I should get something that's like...
Tio, I want taco.
Well, San Ritons.
What is that?
San Ritons.
Oh, wait.
That looks good.
The chili and lamb?
Wait, that looks fucking delicious.
I'm so hungry.
Oh, shit.
Taco's winning.
Never mind.
Tio, I want Puzzle Well, Tio can only get one meal You think
Tio is made of money?
Alright Oh, shit, you're right, it's Taco Tuesday Wait,
you're right, guys, it'd be a crime to not get a taco for
Taco Tuesday day at a Sabri to our tacos are a win for us
night thank you super chat thank you thank you follow me
with super chat thank you thank you thank you and Laura
accurate uncle
uh yeah thank you super chat thank you thank you she's
already celebrating Cruz as a little championship win she's
got a Kagama and is watching the Mexico match it's us with
my father I've risen from the grave thank you super chat
thank you thank you uh Artemis, Alphonse, thank you, super
chat, thank you, thank you, thank you, uh, bro, thank you,
super chat, thank you, now to complete the look, laugh at
the Dutch and scream, no, can I say that?
I don't, I'm worried, I don't know what I'm saying anymore,
I don't know, I don't know, you guys, I'm worried with what
you want me to say, I, wait, Taco Tuesday is not a Mexican
thing, thing by the way Alan thank you super chat thank you
thank you thank you I said thank you the super chat thank
you thank you thank you Tia for that Alan you think I'm
gonna get you think your Tia's gonna get the ask your Tia
for for your mango with chamoy I'm watching the game
It's the taco every day.
You are...
I'm Tio!
Alright, let's see.
Alright, taco wins.
Where are you?
Alright.
You are our Tio.
Now, you tell him Tio.
Truly the Tio experience.
all right let's see taco all right let's get taco and then
all right tacos one all right let's see transparent okay
that we should get a real taco all right uh we gotta find a
good way is this i need to find it hey all right we gotta
give me a Feed dad.
I'll be right back
I'm back I'm back No, he just knows whenever I whenever I'm
like streaming he's like this is my moment This is my moment
to get food right now because she has to she has to she has
to stream All right, I get like a good a good taco though
all right i'm red all right voted by you guys let me grab
half an hour away
wait actually wait why did i put as an image i have to like
attach it to myself give me a sec all right give me a sec
your tears gotta your tears gotta grab the taco No!
Oh, I agree with that.
Oh, is that...
The PNG?
Okay.
Guys, it's a... You can't tell it's a hard shell, guys.
That's...
It's... It was a drawing.
It was definitely soft, guys.
It was definitely soft.
I grabbed the P... I grabbed an artwork.
It was... Wait, does this look like a soft taco?
It's okay.
See, I threw it away, guys.
I threw it away.
You'll actually get canceled.
I'll do a super chat thing.
It's okay.
I threw it away, guys.
I'm trying to find a PNG.
What if I just color the shell?
Like, oh, I know what to do.
I'll recolor it white.
I'll recolor it.
I know what to do.
I'll recolor it white and Move the lines
All right Remove our Mexican Pass
All right Let me see I'm trying to find it Why is it so hard
to find a transparent Taco Is that No I swear to God guys
It's actually really hard to find a transparent Holdable
Taco Uh your passes on do i put a street taco that's like a
real taco i was like avoiding all the hard shell tacos too
because they were i swear they were like the only ones that
were transparent which is like really i was just like why is
it only the hard shell tacos the transparent pictures
all right get a plate you're right maybe Maybe I'll just get
a plate.
I'll just, I'll just grab a, okay, a plate of tacos.
I make my own BNG.
All right, let's see.
Transparent.
Wait, does this work?
Guys.
Guys, okay, before, okay, before I put it in my hand.
I need your opinions.
your opinion my fellow mexicans does this work this does
this work is this is this okay is it where yeah where the
hell are the tacos
yeah all right all right we're putting in my hat close
enough Yeah, all right.
All right, let me put this in my hand.
The council, the council, does the council approve?
Yeah, that's better.
So you do have money.
Yes, that works.
Thank you, Super Checkout.
Yeah, I've had soft shell tacos.
I don't like hard shell tacos, but I love soft shell.
Or soft tacos.
I like I've had it one time like the the card shell and I
was not a fan of it so I don't know whatever get tacos I get
the the soft ones
yeah corn or flour I like both I've had tried corn and flour
I think they're both good uh items all right all right let's
see yeah i like the i like the sophomore all right all right
give me a sec all right teo's getting some tacos right now
let me teo's hungry i'll grab tacos all right
Let's see it.
Alright.
Alright, Tio's back.
Hey!
No!
This is my taco.
Hey!
I worked really hard for these.
Perfect.
That's right.
Tio, please.
Hey!
Get your own tacos.
If you want tacos, you got to work for it.
Just like your deal.
I mean, we're definitely winning now.
Ask your mom and dad.
I'm so hungry.
How do you know how my deal talks?
All right.
Neil, they give a super chat.
Thank you.
Hola, Tio.
Can you give me an un co-co-co-tele de Camarón since it's so
hot?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Aipa, they give a super chat.
Yeah, talk to dad like the Tio too.
Say calate, pero.
They give me a super chat.
Thank you.
All right, let's see.
All right.
We still need a hat.
I keep...
We're always like... We're always just missing a tiny hat.
Sombrero.
And then I can order food.
Alright guys.
I'm gonna show some pictures of sombreros.
And you have to tell me if I can wear it or not.
Uh.
Let's see.
I need like a real sombrero.
Guys, how about this?
Go to use the bird seeders tag or bird seeding tag.
Give me a PN.
Bird seeders tag.
Give me a PNG
side go go and find go and give me a png by the png sombrero
and then yeah i'm outsourcing the sombrero i while i order
food i'm gonna order food now i'm gonna order some mexican
food right now guys i'm hungry i haven't eaten yet Sorry,
Sting.
Alright.
Tio wants to drink and have my taco right now and also
actually order food.
Alright.
Let me see.
I actually need to order food before the game starts.
I don't even think my food's gonna arrive before the game.
23 minutes is not enough time.
but yeah i just i i i gave up because i kept finding fake
pngs so i was like you guys do it
she's actually telling it their job to her nephew's like a
true tio wait i didn't say nephew nephew she's spanish is it
sombre some uh sombre uh sombre uh subnino How do I say it?
Subrino?
Subrino!
Get your Tio a...
Get your Tio a sombrero!
I'm watching the television!
Watching the match, Subrino!
Yeah!
That's right.
Your Tio needs to watch
game I'm lower accurate oh Mijo oh is it Mijo works as well
Mijo that's your deal with the sombrero all right let me it
yeah that tio needs another beer just yet that is easier to
say it all right let's see all right let's see what do i
want to get okay uh oh i want to find something that's all
right guys what should i get wait let me look at what they
have first before i ask I need, like, a place that's, like,
has a lot of reviews, so I know it's good.
4.5?
4.6?
This is sponsored, so I don't know if it's, like, actually
good, good.
Best overall?
I need, like, I want to, like, make it, like, it's, like,
where was the last time?
I don't know, like, the last place I ordered was really,
really good, but I don't remember what it was called.
i want to get nachos i want to get like um because i could
never finish nachos by myself so i don't like ordering
nachos in general just because it's just too much food you
know just too much let's see uh yeah they're gonna super
chat thank you thank you
let's see
Is there any other games going on right now other than oh,
they're all practicing right now.
You'll see them Roberto Alvarad who's who's the star player
on Mexico?
Guys, is it him?
Who's the star player for Mexico?
Is it Roberto?
He just they just showed him Pambazo Gilbert to the uh
I think Quino Quino Quino Quino Quino Quino Nes Quino Nes
Quino's I'm sorry This is my first time reading your names
Or it's like There's like several star players
Closing up Gilberto Mora And Julian Quino I'm just gonna I'm
gonna Google I was like Quinn Quinn So bad at pronouncing
Names Okay Pronunciation I like how I looked up his name And
they're like do you want to look up his wife?
And I was like why
Oh Man okay I Oh okay I know why now Like the first thing is
Like you know the fill in the play and it's like it's like
his name and then wife and I was like why and then I will
wow I could remember yeah yeah okay but look up his wife
though look up his wife And, come on, tell me.
Tell me.
Am I wrong?
Wait, should I get a carnasada?
Oh, wait, the carnasada looks really good.
Tio, you had too much.
Wait, I'm gonna...
Dios mios.
I get...
You had too much.
No valid.
You might have had a little too much to drink.
I'll get cornasada.
What's up, Pastor?
Taco.
Oh, it's marinated pork.
You know, I could get more than one.
Because they're like, there's just one taco.
I like cornasada.
too much try okay a carne carne can i get carne asada and a
pasta a pastor taco oh let's see oh and churros i love
churros i'll get carne asada as well because i like carne
asada yeah a carne asada
all right let's see what else do they have that's a piscato
taco wow that's a lot of oh it's fish i don't know i don't
like it i don't know if i want fish with my on my taco right
now all right let's see there's chori queso mexican chorizo
okay apis there is chori queso uh oh there's so many
different types of oh
guacamole but should i get the chori queso for for apis i
want a burrito because it's like really big like i prefer
tacos over burritos because it's just it's like way i can
never finish a burrito i i could never finish a burrito all
right oh there's quesadillas No, let's get taco since it's
Tuesday.
Yeah, burrito is, like, super heavy.
And I could...
I don't think I've ever finished a burrito in my life.
I always, like, eat, like, half of it.
What are you?
A real teo will finish out burrito.
all right 15 more minutes all right let me see what kind of
what's a toaster in portos
uh oh look at all the mexicans here in jackpully plaza oh
it's a oh that's the oh that's the heart The toasted
tortilla.
Tortilla.
Sorry.
Tia's a little drunk right now.
Oh, wait.
Gerardo's?
That was...
Gerardo's.
Gerardo's good, right?
I'm about to say.
I'm slurring my words.
Do you, do I get Gerados?
Gerati?
Gerritos?
The Geritos?
I don't know.
The Mexican sodas?
I don't pronounce it.
This!
Which one?
What flavor should I get?
There's fruit punch.
There's uh...
There's this...
What is...
Mannerin.
There's mango.
There's pineapple.
What's your favorite?
Haritos?
Oh, is it Haritos?
Which one's your favorite Haritos?
Is the pineapple one?
I think they have all of them.
There's Mexican Cola Harito.
There's Tamarine Harito.
There's lime.
There's guava, grapefruit, pineapple, mango.
Manoran.
which one's your favorite guys
oh there's a lot okay I see a lot of tamarind I'm gonna get
that and then also I'll get the pineapple too because I see
a lot of people saying pineapple I'll get both alright well
I think I hope I didn't order too much food well this is my
first meal of the day so it should be fine alright we're
definitely not eating this like I'm gonna do a priority I
don't know if it's actually be priority but like we're
definitely not we're gonna get this in the middle of the
game during halftime or something
it's yeah
yeah it's my i told you guys i was working all day like i
slept too much yesterday i slept too much yesterday and
that's why your teo is a little drunk we're we're drinking
on an empty stomach
oh wait what's this I got sent a message oh guys guys your
fellow dragoon Alec drew me a sombrero thank you Alec damn
you're fast alright let's see we got a sombrero but yes I
worked all night I slept way too much last night because I
was so tired my body was just so tired and then like so I
when I woke up around like I think like uh did like a lot of
naps last night and i woke at 2 a.m and i stayed up to like
nine to do work stuff and i took another and then i think i
oh wait till like 12 like 11 or something and then i i i uh
took another nap so i've been like working off of nap hours
so this is my first meal all right guys wait this is a
really good sombrero give me a sec let me let me put my hat
on guys Alright, let's see.
My sombrero.
It's so good!
Guys.
Your tears.
Now!
Now I'm an honorary Mexican.
Okay, here we go.
Very perfect.
Me and my miho watching the game.
That's right.
Your meal.
That's you, guys.
That's you.
There we go.
Nailed it.
All right.
Let me look at Mio.
See, guys, Mio got me my sombrero.
It's perfect.
Now that's a Mexican.
I even got the right...
Of course I did.
Wait, let me look through it.
Shout out to the owl for it.
Are they still playing?
Oh, my gosh.
Like, the aisle grew pinged.
Everyone is like, guys, ready for Isle?
I'm watching the game!
Pancho Tocuillo, thank you for the super chat, Dylan, thank
you.
I'm sorry, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
Miho, Alana, got Tio the hat.
Alright, oh my gosh, it's so dark already.
In Mexico City.
Oh, they got to play on the home field, too.
Oh, there it is.
Guys!
Quiet!
It's almost time!
Oh,
it's almost time to gather around the flags.
Tio, Gio, Mate, L-A-L, Commando.
Thank you, Super Chat, Michael.
Thank you, thank you.
Stand up, guys.
Stand up for the national anthem.
Where's your...
Where's your Mexican spirit?
Sing our national anthem, Dio.
We have to get up.
Mio, stand up, Mio.
What are you doing, Mio?
Stand up.
Do we hate Mexico?
Stand up for the national anthem, Mio.
Oh, yeah, we got to get the timer right.
forgot about the timer give me a sec all right oh yeah we
gotta cut the bgm you're right or it's the
there you go i'm ready okay and then the timer too uh
okay it's ecuador's national anthem guys so when is it gonna
arrive okay i'm gonna get my food in 20 minutes
scared of seeing it as someone that my Spanish is really
really bad
I'll hum it I'll hum it who what do you mean the match is
not started yet we had a one-hour delay because I was late
and then God was like God was like we're Where is she?
Lightning.
What's the rank power rankings right now between Mexico and
Ecuador?
Because I know there's a power rankings that World Cup put
out.
It's crazy.
What was it?
Germany, Netherlands, and who else got knocked out?
Sweden, right?
Germany, Netherlands, and Sweden all got knocked out.
I feel like that side.
What's the deaf group?
Like, the right side was, like, a full-on deaf side.
I'm in Japan, too, yeah.
Like, the left side was, like, less crazier than, like, the
match-up on the right side.
Mexico!
Miho!
Stand up, miho!
Yeah!
Let's go!
Let's fucking go!
Let's play some soccer!
I'm singing in my head, guys.
Let's play some football!
My ears!
Vominus!
Let's play ball!
Yes, I gotta say both.
Soccer and football.
She said, stop canceling.
Stand up, Mio.
All right, guys, whatever happens, we don't make me into
salsa.
Whatever.
Whatever happened.
It's because Mio didn't stand up.
From this Canadian fan, let's go, Mexico.
Folly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I told you, I was thinking of the super chat.
Mexican hymn lyrics are actually wild.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm ready.
You'll become a pinata.
No!
Please don't make me a marketable pinata.
Whoops.
All right, we're going to get the timer.
ready if mexico is mexico loses i've been wanting to try the
neck the new salsa recipe yes we yes we got ecuador uh jay
they give the five gift and chips they can thank you i'm
ready to start it oh there's there's we're wait where's mora
oh there you go gilberto mora and then oh there you go
there's Julian 19 and 16.
I always like wonder oh my god he looks so young oh my god
Gilberto Mora how old is Gilberto Mora he looks like I'm
sorry he looks he looks so young he's like a chai my little
chai he's like my miho miho that's you I 17 yeah I was gonna
say I see it He looks like he's in the middle of puberty
right now.
Oh, my bro.
That, that's, he's like a prodigy.
Yeah.
Miho.
That's you, miho.
He is a child.
Like, an actual little child.
I was not ready to see him actually be 17.
I was like, he looks young.
He is a miho.
Crystal, thank you, super child.
Thank you.
Yeah, 17 are already in the big leagues, too, and he's
already in the World Cup.
Mexico for the win.
Why is that tomato wearing a somberto?
That's your teahoe.
Respect me.
I didn't matter.
Respect.
There's a child playing in the World Cup right now.
Taylor, do you have a super chat?
Thank you.
Where are we watching this?
Asset 7.
Mexico.
Thank you.
The super chat.
I'm getting ready to start timer and that's our work message
real quick.
Was he actually 16 when he started?
That's crazy.
And like for it is actually crazy.
starting timer.
I swear to God if I I swear to God if I see Haram Ball, I
swear to I'm time i'm sorry i'm i'm so tired of if i if i
see some haram ball i swear to god i'm not ready for i'm oh
for those who don't know haram balls so like remember what
we were doing all the passing and everything and then
there's a fucking there's like 20 people on the field i
swear to god like that's a haram ball you will learn to love
the haram.
That's what it is.
I swear to God.
Do not make me watch more haramba.
That's your soccer not in my game.
How do I tell you?
He embraced the haramba.
Yeah, it's basically turtling.
That's what we like, You know how it's just like, oh my god,
they're just passing.
They're just passing.
Oh, wow, ref!
Ref!
Ref, he can walk, ref!
He can walk!
Ref, he can walk, it's fine.
Someone send in the patch notes a nerf harambo.
Why do we...
Okay.
He's got legs.
If he can walk, it's fine.
He loves Saranba.
Super.
He was super chat.
Thank you.
It's been there.
He's still breathing.
It's only one minute.
Let it...
Oh, don't pass.
Oh, do I want to pass again?
Okay, thank God.
All right.
There you go.
I call for pass.
I call for nerfs, guys.
send more.
When will they nerf Harambo?
Marco, thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
I can't wait for the stats.
don't do this to me, Mexico.
Don't...
Mexico, don't do this to me.
T-ho, mad.
When it stops working, only God can nerf Harambo.
But the meta is strong, do you?
You can run faster.
That's right.
You're so much.
Use those legs, Mihal.
Use those legs.
Yes.
Good pass.
Come on.
You get...
Oh my god.
Is that...
Child.
Mihal, run.
Mihal.
Oh, no.
Ref.
Foul.
I saw Mora running.
I was like, use those legs.
It's still growing.
You can still grow.
It's a child.
Oh, oh my God.
Okay.
Pass.
Those are some good.
Holy shit.
Oh my God.
That's a good cross.
That's a good, that's a really good cross.
Oh, what kind of fucking pass was that, miho?
Miho.
why reset it was there oh it's because haram ball is it
because there's 20 people there is it what was that pass
these are like all like insane passes and then the last pass
fucking sucks the detrit
guys guys
yeah it's so close they're like all good passes until the
five pass and then they whiff it.
Alright.
Come on.
Like, like, the crosses are so good.
But like, like, they set everything up and then the five.
Come on, y'all!
No!
Good attempt, though.
Good attempt, miho.
Good attempt.
I gotta love Haramba.
Yeah, I'm accurate.
That was close.
It was close.
It
was close one, Miho.
We just need 10 more of those.
10 more of those.
So close.
That is mad.
Holy, okay, now guys, okay.
Calm down.
Calm down, Miho.
Little too, too, too enthusiastic, bro.
A little, a little bit of, Calm down.
You're getting a little too excited there.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's what you needed to pass.
Yeah, the shootout's too high.
Hey, free ball, though.
Free ball.
Don't get, yeah.
Pass was literally right there.
He wanted to be the first goal.
That's what I was thinking, too.
I was like, that.
They could have, like, the one time they actually needed a
pass.
Oh, there he goes.
There's the child.
Oh, my God.
Oh my god.
There's no one.
Yes.
Come on.
That was so close.
These are so good passes.
It's like they set it up perfectly, too.
Come on.
Bro, did you not get a good head today?
Bro, come on.
Where's your head game?
Where is it?
Too fair.
It was better than Canada's head game, though.
It was a weekend.
Mexico is playing really good.
good right now i will say yeah pause at least it's like
better than gana's headies were really bad i like at least
there's like oomph to it he just didn't he didn't aim it
that was the only issue he just he just had to like jerk it
to the right
all right
Oh my god.
Wait, that's a sick ass pass.
Oh, yeah, but I don't think he's faster.
Is he?
Oh, wait.
Free?
Oh, it's a that's good.
That's good.
But they they like delayed the momentum.
The momentum's gone.
Oh, what?
Okay.
What the fuck was that?
He just he's like he's like pass and he's like shoot.
What the fuck was that free throw?
they're like way too i think they're like it's like they're
it's good that they're aggressive but there's sometimes
they're like way too aggressive it was miss input yeah like
you put he pressed b guys he accidentally ran all right bro
passed it
all right all right miho's got the ball come on miho come on
miho come on miho come on miho come on He tripped.
He tripped a child.
Ref, that's a child.
He tripped him.
Come on, miho.
The child of Boon abuse.
He's not legal yet.
If you trip him, it's against the law.
Use that to your advantage, man.
to go.
He's just a little.
That's child abuse.
You're looking.
That kid's 17.
He's not even 18 yet.
That's assault on a minor.
Yellow card, ref.
Yellow card.
To keep police.
Okay.
a trail
oh these headies are real are like these like passes are
insane i like it's like okay watching okay i don't for those
who don't remember cadda's game like two days ago like
cadda's passes versus mexico passes is like night and day
like these passes are crazy the cross and everything are
insane.
It's just like the end.
The end when they set up the goal is just terrible right
now.
It's like they set it up and they just don't, don't like...
Oh no, no!
Grab it!
Good defense!
Don't let him set it up!
Good deed, good deed.
Oh my god, that was crazy.
That was a crazy defense from that guy.
Holy shit.
The fucking block Nice Holy shit Oh, the jukes Oh my god The
fucking jukes there Oh Are you serious?
Get the fuck up, ref That guy, that's the grass Ref, it was
raining earlier Ref, you think, look at that What did he do?
He grabbed What?
It was What?
Bro, tripped on the wet grass.
What was that?
Bro.
No shine.
I could tell it wasn't even a foul.
You know, that was actually him tripping.
All right, where's the ref from?
Guys, give me the bloodline.
Who paid off the grass?
Oh, nice, nice.
Ref!
Wait, no, that's not a miho, though.
So, yes, he touched it.
He touched it.
He touched it, guys.
He ref is bloodline is crazy.
How do we tell it?
Check his bloodline.
Track his bloodline down.
Tell me where he's from.
what's his death 23 and me him right now i need a note
apollo thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
that's great i that was such a shitty call that is obviously
not a not a foul like actually he was so far he was
literally grabbing on
all right holy shit like where he's sending that kick dude
like to fucking nanya like wait to see where is he what to
the other side of the goalkeeper check his poly market
check if he has a poly market kid hey no no what no no oh
god okay i'm not missing this you're not making me miss this
oh wait there's nobody there there's nobody there No, yeah,
no Wait, no, there's no more fluid.
Why south south?
No All right
I'm watching our TSN
Okay, that's good.
That's a corner kick though.
We got the corner kick in that's good Tio is speaking
Chinese my Tio knows Chinese
I do wonder if my food will arrive slower because they're
all watching the game.
I do wonder.
I'm just wondering if my food will arrive slower because
everyone's watching the game right now.
What?
I swear to God, off.
I swear to God, there's no way that's off.
Oh, yes!
Yes!
Get
him!
Get that guy!
It'll never...
I do think that's to their advantage, though, because it
lets them set up the corner kick again, you know?
Like, I feel like them doing, like, disrupting the corner
kick is really good for Ecuador in general, just because it
just loses the momentum.
Oh, that was close.
Yeah.
Because, like, they know...
Because, like, the initial corner kick was good.
And then they changed...
They, like, knew their strat, and then they, they, like,
changed.
They had to, like, redo it again.
That was close.
That was so close, too.
Yeah, there's so many good shots from Mexico right now
versus Ecuador.
Oh, my God, it is raining.
What the fuck?
So close, Miho.
Yeah, that's four.
Oh, in 15 minutes.
That's insane.
Like, Oh my god, look at those headies.
Look at those.
Don't let the ball touch the ground.
Don't...
The floor is lava.
Keep the momentum.
Be home.
You broke the chain.
You broke...
Oh.
Unlucky.
Unluck.
The fact that, like, the ball stayed in the...
Like, the momentum for, like, what, 10 seconds?
like that those those players got some head game
oh nice deal oh you gotta run you gotta run miho you gotta
run for it
62% possession versus 30 that's insane that's actually
insane Mexico's doing really well like just stealing the
ball oh no wait wait wait oh I mean the pass is alright it's
a good cross oh like oh wait don't i do it oh no oh that was
close that was close oh my god that i will say the way
ecuador set that up was insane that was such a crazy good
setup from ecuador like like he whipped the shot but like
literally oh my god he if he shot right it would have been
went in that was insane shot that was an insane play from
Ecuador.
Like, literally, it was just there for him.
Like, the momentum was so fast.
Yeah, like, they might not have all that.
I feel like every time Ecuador has had the ball for,
has, oh my god, that was so scary.
Every time Ecuador has had the ball to make the shot, they
are all, like, really, like, it's all perfectly set up for
them.
But they just like with it the very last second like mexico
had more attempts trying to get the shots in but they like
forced shots in but ecuador is like every time they get a
they get like shots in it's like perfectly set up for them
where it's like it's it should be in yeah i think like they
only attempt for shots when they think they can get it like
100 try to get it in but they don't get it in
Yeah, you can tell, like, Mexico is, like, more offensive
than defensive.
Because, like, I saw, like, every...
Like, they have three really good setups for it.
Where the defense was, like, just wasn't there.
Like, look at that.
Like, like, it's set up so perfectly for them, too.
It's, like, when Mexico has the ball majority, 80% of the
time, like, there would be, like, seven players at the goal.
Oh, no, this is getting close.
Nice!
Get that ball out of here!
It's okay, you're faster!
You're so much...
Where's... Where... Where... Where... Where are... Where's
people?
Wait, what happened?
What?
What happened?
Oh!
They're like, yeah, we did that.
Yeah.
What a push, yet The other guy's like He's like, I did that
He's like, you did, you did do that Like Guys, what the fuck
was that?
And then the other players that were Like, the other's like,
what the fuck, bro?
And the two guys that were pushing Like, I did it, yeah, I
did
He's like, oh, you did it, didn't you?
He's like, oh, yeah, I did It was me.
That doesn't mean the game isn't getting good.
Yeah, the shoulder check there.
I like the people who are mad weren't even, like, part of
the problem.
Oh, shit.
Grab him back.
I, looking at this, Canada was definitely much, more
physical.
Oh, oh, the setup!
Oh, my God!
It was a perfect shot.
The perfect fucking shot.
No, the thing is, I was like, was that, I was like, go, and
then, you know what, he was like, he wasn't reacting, so I
was so confused.
I was like, was it offside?
I was like, did you see him?
He did not react to the goal.
So I was like, go, huh?
Like,
like, he didn't react.
Look at him.
Like, he didn't react.
Yeah.
That's, I was so scared.
I was like, is that offside?
The offside scared.
Go.
Even he was like, even he was like, is it offside?
Oh, my God.
In 22 minutes.
minutes bro was buffering bro bro was like did i make that
in yeah first goal first goal yeah i was just like i because
i was like that can't be offside but then he didn't react to
the goal you know when you get in the guy would like freak
out instantly and be like oh no but he was just like huh and
then he was like He was literally fucking buffering IRL.
So I was so confused.
Oh, yeah, 1-0.
1-0.
I was so confused.
I was like, am I not supposed to react?
Did it not go, is it, got called off?
It was perfect.
Bro had no confidence.
Yeah, I was like, there's no way that's offside.
So I was like, why aren't you reacting to your goal, bro?
like oh
there it boom put off of out of here get that shit out of
here nerf that shit nerf haram ball nice steal though that
was an insane steal he's just nonchalant like that he had a
hundred packet loss the ping guys oh my god yes Yes!
What?
No!
You're really gonna give...
Oh, hydration break.
Hydration.
Okay, guys.
I was gonna say, you're really gonna give the foul to the
Haramba team?
Really, ref.
You're only encouraging this meta.
You're just encouraging this meta, ref.
Really.
You're really gonna go with that.
A hydration break, guys He stopped the MexiTac for a fucking
break That's crazy He actually stays like Guys, guys, I know
he's about to Go on offensive, guys But water's very
important, everyone Miho Miho Another beer Miho
They're like, guys, the ads paid the spot for here Guys, we
just scored This is the perfect time to run more ads
Alright, hydration break Okay, that gives me enough time to
actually answer This work message real quick Alright, wait,
can I Can I ask My friends to help Me pick
I don't know if I can show it.
Okay, I'm going to give Dad another treat because he's
getting a little too bratty right now.
Time for it to kill the break.
Hey.
He goes back.
I came again.
I gotta watch my matches.
Gotta watch my game.
Alright.
We're almost...
yeah i got back just in time no i have my food yeah i'm
pretty sure the restaurant's like watching the game so it's
a lot slower i'm pretty sure oh 100 oh yeah no because it
was supposed to arrive like in five minutes and then they
updated like 20 they added 20 more minutes to timer like
it's football like they're like we gotta add minutes in for
all the delay yeah no they added 20 more minutes to the
timer.
Yeah, food's gonna might come at the end of the game.
Yeah, even the chefs are watching it.
Giovanni.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hydration break time to open the tequila.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Mr. Burns.
Nice.
Thank you.
Super chat.
Alright.
Is this a... Oh, is this free?
What is he doing?
I'm giving birth right now.
It's a ball.
Just ask for a new ball.
Can't you just ask for a new ball?
I'm just like, why are you wiping the ball of your jersey?
He's like, I'm pregnant, guys.
It's a ball.
What is this?
Is this ours?
Is this our kick?
No ball.
I'm pregnant.
That's true.
It is raining.
So the ball is more wet.
So where's the towel boys?
You know, like, you know how, like, in tennis, they have the
little, like, the, the tennis boys that pick up the tennis
balls?
Where the fuck are my, where the fuck are my soccer boys?
the ball
Mia bring the towel yeah the the ball guys the ball boys
oh there was no one there to set it up it would have been a
really good pass if they had one guy just one guy over there
it would actually been a really good pass like There was
literally no one there for the setup.
Oh, that shit.
Oh, oh, my God.
Wait, oh, he was faster.
Wait, wait.
What the fuck was that pass?
Oh, shit.
Yes.
Come on.
Step.
Yes.
Yeah.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
That was great.
That was a good.
That was a good shot from watching this game after Canada
version.
versus South Africa no Canada's fucked I'm sorry I'm sorry
Canada's so fucked bro I want this because I'm watching this
game after Canada man like like where I'm actually seeing
real setups real crosses real fucking like passes that work
good head game good chess game like no bro i i swear i saw
90 minutes of haram ball last cap
oh my god two oh let me set up the thing i'm sorry canada
but we all know that we we we made it but we still we still
want all the favorites to lose oh thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you bro i guys i'm too scared to watch
canna versus morocco guys canna versus morocco might be
might be scary i
that was what wait we need america to lose so we can have
guys guys if america makes it through guys come all in top
16 guys yeah the united states and mexico
Come would all be in top 16.
We just need the U.S.
to win.
I do not.
Learning the joy of cheering for Latin American country
football in its veins.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What is all host countries?
But then all the host countries gets in.
One Nation Undercome.
And Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Bro, the come bros.
They're gonna, we gotta get the come bros.
What the fuck was that?
Bro, he was getting, he was getting a little frisky there.
Yeah, he was like, I can't stop myself.
I'm just, yeah, that was a little silly, you guys.
Why, ref, why did you stop?
them oh oh my god the fucking slap yeah it's so one point on
the leash guys you got grep why did you stop them they're
just getting started yowie in my soccer game wow no wonder
joki got more invested they had you might say they had a
heated rivalry
Guys, without the U.S., we'll just be CM or MC.
Guys, we need the U to complete the trifecta.
Yay, he touched him.
Ref.
Wait, that's not me, ho.
Tokey, please.
Look at him.
He can't walk.
He's broken his leg a minute.
Red card.
Look at him.
Oh my god.
He punched him.
Rep.
Did you not see that?
He fucking slapped the man.
Give him a red card.
He even pulled out a knife.
Rep.
He pulled out a knife and started stabbing.
He pulled out a red card.
Give him the rep that you not see in the replay.
Rep.
Revy, he literally threw a grenade.
What is he to rivalry?
It's what we're watching right now.
He's got a gun, ref.
Red card.
Meadow, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's homosexual.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I've been a Bosnia fan my whole life.
I was born last week, Mr. Myflavikins.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's crazy.
It's only 36 minutes of the game.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Welcome to Gums.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right, guys.
During halftime, I gotta have you guys pick something real
quick.
I need you guys to pick.
This is for the VIP for the concert.
people during halftime because we're watching football
all right what
the fuck was that bullshit call ref the guy can walk if he
can walk it's fine what was that call ref that man can walk
bro what the fuck was that if
he He can walk, he's fine.
He exists, he's fine.
Park the bus!
Park it!
Oh, nice.
Yeah, that's good.
That's good.
Good.
Score another goal.
Defeat their mental.
Make them desperate.
Score another goal.
What the fuck was that bad?
I feel like the fact that it's raining is doing a huge
advantage with with Mexico right now.
I feel like Ecuador is not used to playing in the rain or
something because they're like fumbling with some like
they're fumbling.
Like I don't know.
They're slipping a lot.
Yeah.
Oh, I say that in Mexico slips.
Go take care of the coffee.
We saw a month ago.
That's I'm sure I got.
I gotta get my cough drop in.
Yeah, it's like a slip and slide.
Wow!
Nice save.
Holy shit.
That gold dies on an insane save.
Oh my god.
I got...
send a message from Ben from the, like, if you guys didn't
know, like, when I played with the Iowa Shore 4 goalie and
Ben, and he DMed me, and he was like, ah, no time.
And I replied back, Mexico time.
That, nice, nice head.
Nice head.
That's a goalkeeper, yeah.
wait i said yeah i'll send him a screenshot or i'll send him
and golly golly's a mexican by the way
he said it was golly wait that was golly's not even in here
Goli was the one that sent me the song.
Viva Mexico, cool arrows.
Bally, thank you for super chat.
Thank you.
We have Dino time after the match.
Lolly, thank you for super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You might have to get Dino time.
Wait, I just pulled it down.
It's beautiful.
Yes.
Yes, I showed Goli.
Wait, you didn't- Fan was like, wait, that was your stream?
He didn't realize it was me.
He didn't- I didn't realize that this was me.
They're like, Boo!
Tomato is the real me.
We're almost close to halftime.
Four more minutes.
Nice, nice D!
Get up!
Game's still going!
Oh.
Like, maybe my tacos would get here soon.
I still have...
Oh, 13 minutes till my tacos are here.
Holy shit.
What the fuck is that match momentum graph?
Like, what the...
What is this?
Look at the first, like, 10 minutes of that graph.
That's crazy.
Bro, everybody's watching the game.
I mean, it's a good game.
Is this...
Oh, that was a really good pass.
Come on, keep running!
Miho!
Miho, you still have lots of growing to do!
Oh!
Bad head.
Yeah, it's a stock rep.
Sell, buy, buy, sell, buy, sell.
you can run it's alright your bones will heal faster because
you're so young just run you'll recover faster miho your
body is still fresh oh my god what a fucking steal
another close one yeah but we're doing having more
possessions though yeah see nine attempts at goal versus
Versus three.
All right.
Oh, good pass.
Come on, set up.
It set up for you.
Perfectly.
Oh, what the?
Oh, I think he should have made the shot.
I legitimately think he should have just went for it.
That was like, look, like, I don't know.
I feel like I, like that was a little too safe.
Yeah.
Because making that pass gave him time to get to the goal
faster.
He hesitated.
Like, literally, he had so much free space to make that
shot.
And in the moment he did a pass, all the defense players
already swarmed the fucking goal.
They already parked a goddamn plane.
Yeah, it was just too much hesitation there.
Mio is too short.
Someone quick teach him the head game.
Oh, halftime.
Wait, is it not?
halftime is it not five minutes are they adding five minutes
time oh no they're adding five minutes all right never mind
not half time yeah plus five because of plus five i saw five
but i couldn't like you know sometimes they put the sign up
for like substitution swaps so i didn't realize if it was
like subs or or half time or plus five minutes boom
oh yeah that hydration break push him away it's legal it's
us yeah yellow could yeah yeah he pulled out a gun ref ref
he pulled out a gun yeah that's what you get that's what you
get
You get a replay of that?
Let's see, what did he do?
What did he do?
Good, good job, good job.
Make sure to, make sure to land, make sure to lay on the
floor for 20 more minutes, bro.
Good job, good job.
I will, I will.
Literally hit him with a bow driver.
Good, good.
The acting class is paying off, guys.
Just stay on the floor.
He
didn't even touch him, Ref.
Ref, he didn't touch him.
Look at that.
Look, he jumped over.
What the fuck, bro?
What was that?
Find this man's polymarket.
Find...
Guys, we still don't know where he's from, guys.
I see no blood.
That was actually bullshit.
He did not trip him.
That guy fucking jumped.
He, like, slipped on the grass.
Guys, who paid off the grass?
That was not a fault.
100%.
Nice.
All right, good.
Yeah, fuck you.
That's what you get for getting a fake fault.
That's what you'll get That's right That's karma Elgrass L
rep
That's right That's karma Karma for those acting classes bro
I don't
long till my food's here Eight more minutes guys I'm
actually getting my food during halftime where the grass is
from?
Where is the grass imported?
That grass was not born on Mexican soil.
I refuse to believe that.
Where did they import the grass?
I do wonder if it's like American football.
Because you know, you're always using your head for
headbutts and stuff.
And so I'm just wondering, like because they don't wear
helmets, obviously.
Why?
and check the grass's blood oh shit yes good good save good
slide good slide who cares if you're bleeding from grass
burn you fight for your country
i 23 hit me the grass
i see so many like headbutts here headies for this game i
see so many headers yeah let's go good half that's a good
half that that's football that's soccer right there
all right we have four or five more oh i gotta stop stop the
clock.
We stopped the clock.
It's 2-0 right now.
Oh, hey!
It's the... How do you pronounce his name again?
That guy, you guys told me it was a star player.
All right, miho.
Give Tio another beer.
I'm almost done with this one, miho.
No, this was... I told you when I soccer it was i was not
joking when i said it was piss poor soccer like it's it was
it's literally i'm happy canna made it the top 16 but that
match was that match it was just a standstill like
yeah miho my beer's getting too warm me a cold one miho yeah
no the game this game is uh uh fucking intense it was so
slow it was just so much harambo at like i like i don't want
i don't know i like i think canada did less harambo but like
it was just the like south africa literally parked the bus
every time it was like goddamn a goddamn like bus a tank and
a plane parked in front of the goal every time and then
canada's passing was just not it i think this the swiss game
was better than the the swiss game was better than the south
africa game watching it side by side uh but like um i'm
happy canada made it though that was it was a good shot
though in the end like the the shot from canada was really
good but to it was was was a lot it was it was a lot it was
just a lot to watch like it just a lot
all right wait okay guys okay vip wait let's see you did
they make it yet all right i'm gonna have to add a watermark
for this myself real quick how long is half time Do I have
for halftime, guys?
Alright, I need to add a watermark to this myself.
Because I think they're busy right now.
Alright, 15 minutes.
Okay, I have 15 minutes to do this.
And I have 2 minutes till my food gets here.
Alright, give me a sec.
I have to add a watermark to this real quick.
Propane.
Oh, it's Hulu on Disney Plus.
You don't have my... Oh, shit.
Where do I where did i put my bottle opener that's my only
oh i know i have it oh shit i oh no oh okay we're i don't
know where my bottle opener is i just realized because i
can't open my my bottle and it's here oh no wait is it in
here I have like a little box of McNacks So I have two I
just don't know where Both of them are Oh no Guys How am I
going to open my Are you pronouncing Haritos?
How am I going to open that?
I don't know where my bottle opener is I'm so bad With using
it against the table I had my nail clippers, but where's my
bottle opener?
Oh, no.
Guys, I don't know where my bottle opener is.
I had it here.
Simpsons predicted Mexico versus Portugal finals.
Sorry for the finals.
Spoilers.
They did a super chat thinking, thank you.
All right, we're going to try using the edge of the table.
All right, wait, let me make this watermark real quick.
all right what are they talking about oh there's a lot a lot
of a lot of mexicans for the show all right let me i'm gonna
make a watermark real quick do not steal
there we go all right and then i gotta resize this to six
i'll do 600 all right i need to write do not steal and then
let me resize all of this
all right oh my gosh those goals were so good too i i'm i'm
like damn that's a good shot like there's some oomph to the
shots too which was nice to see That's football.
That's going to be Canada one day, guys.
That's going to be us one day.
It doesn't matter.
We made it.
We claw.
We claw, guys.
We fucking claw.
It doesn't matter.
In the end, we clawed.
Doesn't matter how we got there.
But Canada was there.
Canada clawed.
We did it.
All right.
A fractured skull?
Someone.
wrap that man's head in bandages what do you mean a
fractured skull who has a fractured skull
all right let me all right all right so this is for um um oh
all right okay so we have an hour to we have to pick this
like now all right so This is for the VIP postcards.
I need you guys to help me decide All right, so Paint
splatter This is for the VIP This is my watermark, by the
way Dude, is this fine?
Like, this is for the postcard, guys This one Full white Do
not steal
Or...
This is for the VIP ticket holder.
So you get a signed postcard from me that's included.
Or...
Or the purple.
There you go.
Oh, you're right.
It's okay.
It's very tiny.
It's very...
Let's try...
Long live the purple ghost they're on I don't know which one
All right so but it's gonna be signed too so let me let me
make the watermark a little better I don't know maybe it's
not as good Does it do not steal come with it do it not
steal there you go I'll add more guys I'll add more
i know that's crazy he's like 17 too all right let me he's
not the youngest right no he's not because you guys said uh
messy was 16 right when he did the when when he first played
for world cup do not steal guys that's illegal
Please do not steal.
You wouldn't steal a postcard, would you?
Can I fucking move this?
Alright, there you go.
How much longer till half-time's over, guys?
We still need to do a vote.
Oh my god, I'm almost done, guys.
Alright, and then...
Oops.
There we go.
Alright.
watermark.
I don't think it matt.
All right, here we go.
There we go.
Is that better?
Is that...
All right.
We're going to go left, middle, right.
All right, we're going to... This is where the VIP ticket
holders.
I'm going to make a poll.
All right.
All right, here we go.
Here we go.
uh for the vip postcard concert left white oh wait no that's
not paint splatters uh this is for my concert uh middle it's
autographed white right purple so if you so you get to
decide.
Which one do you guys want?
This is for the VIP postcard.
For the VIP postcard holders.
Yeah, that's what mine's concerned with.
The right one sort of blends in a little too much.
That's what I was most concerned about.
But this is for the...
Like I said, this is for the VIP postcard.
Like, people who bought the VIP tickets on the venue and
they'll get a sad postcard of this.
So whichever one you guys won.
Guys, I think I know which one's winning.
When are they gonna call?
Come on.
Give me my taco.
Guys, halftime's almost over.
Where's my taco?
I don't think they want me to vote for them.
Majority.
You know what?
Voting matters.
Decide their fate.
Non-VIP holders.
Control what they're gonna get.
You got to control their fate.
I'm not VIP, so I'm choosing the worst one.
That's messed up, bro.
The VIP owners are already heading to the venue.
Don't get it.
I give them.
So for us, that cannot make it, are you agreeing to like,
will there be a merch of the VIP stuff available online to
buy too?
So thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Unfortunately, the postcard won't be for sale because it's
like giving us like a little perk for VIP VIP ticket
holders.
But all the other merch will be online that you can buy.
And you also buy in venue too.
You buy on venue and also online.
This is for the...
But yes, if you guys want to check out my concert, streaming
tickets are out now.
Half time, ready to chill.
Yes.
If you guys want to buy a stream, streaming ticket for my
concert.
You can right now.
On the top right corner you can change the language to
English.
There you go, guys.
You can buy the streaming ticket too.
And also watch a lot with everyone for my birthday.
Hey, it's halftime.
I can also have my own ad.
It is halftime.
guys I should be legally allowed to have me to run ads you
can no okay wait who is the cloud but think of this way you
can also buy my streaming ticket and also watch when they're
haram balling you know when they start haram balling you can
pull up the stream of my concert my Mexico I was there for
you Mexico you could be there for me too i give you guys two
goods miho miho come on miho watch it watch your teo dance
all right all right so i think all right i think the the All
right, the white postcard.
Oh, no, the left paint splatter.
Okay, I'll give that to.
I'll let them know.
They all majority wants the paint splatter.
Yeah, Fotejo.
Fotejo.
All right.
Oh, they're back on the field.
Final call for votes, guys.
call.
Half time's almost over.
We're going to start at 45.
Oh, they're changing right now.
Alright, maturity wants the light paint splatter.
Alright, light paint splatter wins.
Thank you for voting, everybody.
It's a 3D concert.
concert and we have uh oh wait oh my gosh the game's
starting so i can't guys guys we'll we'll show at the end
we'll show at the end guys i'll show the the graphic of
everything too um but it's a 3d concert and it's like it's
like nostalgia theme so we have a lot of nostalgic songs a
lot a lot punk rock rock emo gas classic pop like pop from
the 2000s the 2010s um Guys, I can still chill.
Alright, there we go.
Alright, add it over.
Oh my god, he got closer.
He actually got closer.
Where's my taco?
Hey, no, no.
Why?
Moya maya.
Alright.
Why?
Moya.
Sao.
Alright.
my my uber east driver cannot find a parking spot keep
playing keep playing he can still walk walk over him walk
his legs are still functional
just walk over him
all right that's all that passes too hot high
Get Mexican now.
Marisa, they have a super chat.
Thank you.
You cannot find a parking spot right now.
Why am I tomato?
I'm going to be salsa.
You all have a little dokey in your salsa.
Because I'm spicy.
Okay.
I'm hot
I finally some good fucking food
How come she's 10 second Head I'm 5 I'm literally right next
to the stadium Right now that's why
I'm watching Like you know how like I don't have a ticket
But I'm like standing on like a couple of Boxes and looking
down into the Arena that's me
I have a PC set up next to a stadium.
I have like a hundred boxes and I'm on top of the hundred
boxes and just watching, looking down into the stadium.
I'm watching from the windows.
You're dead.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Saul, she's a miner.
Whoa, whoa.
Child!
Red card!
Ref!
He's a minor!
Assault!
Not my meal!
He's just a little guy.
No, I said he!
They got a free shot.
I said he!
Oh nice head Where's my yellow card Oh keep going Keep going
He bumped into him He bumped into him Did you not see Replay
that video Replay that video You can tell he hit him first
My boy was just standing still My boy was standing My top
tacos finally almost here my which is it
was that word for me when i have like the doki the doki
language when i start slurring my words i start mumbling but
my cold tacos are gonna be here soon
i'm not drinking by the way i'm not but i am actually i
should pre-game because i have to record something with
matara today and she wanted me to pre-game she wanted me to
drink with her while we do the recording
big deal not drinking oh my free ball though someone just
got like 500 like not even five $1,000, Richie.
What?
He already had food.
I don't even know why he's barking.
That's right.
Go warm up.
Go warm up in case we need to send you back in.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Keep going, keep going, oh!
Wait, wait, wait.
Because if they touch it...
Oh, yes!
Yes!
Get that tapping!
That's right.
He had the last touch.
He knows I'm going to get tacos.
He's going to bark with the tacos, too.
I can't wait for my tacos.
Oh, oh my God.
They have 20 people.
10, 20...
Where's the 18th player?
I put him on.
Get all of them on the field.
12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18.
Get them all in.
Put all the subs in, too.
Oh, my food's here.
All right, guys.
My food's here.
Don't do anything.
Keep her ramballing.
I don't care.
Just her ramballing.
Oh, shit.
I'm here.
Don't score.
Don't.
I saved the game.
You're welcome.
I showed I came back and then he missed.
You're welcome, everyone, buddy.
You're fucking welcome.
I, yeah, I did pause.
She came back and said, yeah, that's right.
My presence.
My, the hero.
All right, let's see.
I can use the table to open this.
Oh, my God, it broke the wall!
Guys, it's not working.
Guys, I'm trying to, I'm trying to get, I'm trying to open
this.
It did a deal for the save.
But I'm the Ecuador fan.
I swear to God, they scored the goal out two years away.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, I don't know where my, I don't know where my, I don't
know where my bottle opener is guys i didn't have time to
find it during half time
where is it is it like okay guys will we be safe i'm gonna
go away for 10 seconds guys wait after this part after oh
all right wait oh okay wait i can't It's a bottle cap.
Oh, I can.
Wait, no, I can't.
I can twist it, but I can't open it.
I can't pop it.
Keep going, keep going.
It's okay.
Keep going.
They're acting.
They're so healthy.
They're...
Wait.
What's going on?
what the replay guys my my player is on the ground longer
than the other players so like yellow card on him all right
what happened what the oh foul yellow red card red why did
you fall why why did the other guy why did the other guy
fall bro he's like i tripped him go i need to fall What?
Bro to kick the Mexican player and was like, my leg!
Like the Mexican player's leg was made of steel.
And he's like, oh, my toes!
His leg was made of steel.
And my leg, his shin was so high.
He kicked the cat somehow Easy
Oh shit Get that ball Yes get that ball out
That's funny that you think I have A can opener It's funny
as you think I'm The only can Food I buy is spam There's no
need for can openers when you have spam.
Guys, I need to leave.
Please, I need to leave.
Please, mijo.
And Tio needs to leave for 10 seconds so Tio can drink.
Mijo.
Alright, alright.
I'm gonna...
10 seconds.
10...
Oh my god.
I need to go open my drink.
Alright.
I'm back.
So the cat opener is not in the kitchen.
It's somewhere here in my room.
And I just need to figure out where it is.
It's somewhere here.
I need to put my cat over.
I said my bottle opener.
My bottle opener.
Where is it?
Keep defending Mexico.
I need a bottle opener.
This is an emergency.
I need a drink.
oh my where is it i know it's in this room oh i found it it
was i found it red card okay i got it oh i i opened the
wrong one i opened the pineapple i wanted to drink the
tamarind
whatever i'll just drink that I drank, I opened the wrong
bottle.
I was trying, I was supposed to open the tap right.
All right.
Well, that's the churros.
I want to eat the churros.
All right, let's see which one is this.
Oh, that's a, what's it called?
The Teresa one?
Oh, that looks good.
Got my Mexican food, guys.
Thank you, miho.
Thank you.
The child has been benched.
Don't worry, they'll put him back in the last 10 minutes or
some shit.
He just needs to rest.
He's a growing boy.
You need to feed him calories right now.
Feed him like 10, 20,000 calories right now so he can go
back in.
I'm not...
No, not taco.
It's the, it's the appetizer.
What is it called again?
I don't remember what it's called.
Oh, it is good.
The cheese and chorizo one.
What is it called?
The chorizo.
Yeah, chorizo queso.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got that.
I'm getting the appie first.
Got the appies in.
And then I'll eat the taco.
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
I actually pressed the space bot.
I'm so relaxed now.
Come on, make sure you go get another goal.
Go another one.
Break their spirit.
Must be fucking nice being home stadium.
Must be really fucking nice, guys.
US and Mexico must be nice we're in LA the Swiss kicked us
out the fucking Swiss kicked us out of our country they're
like we're gonna establish another another bank here
I'm just playing LA right now
the swiss stadium now
What's it called when people we're we're gonna make you add
another or offshore banking We need another we need another
country to store some And the store the funds Wow get in
here Get in here
Oh, this is good though
Oh, they brought me a lot they got give me the The green one
and the red one.
I know the green one, because the green one, the green one
was the really spicy one, right?
I forgot what the sauce was called.
The green one.
Doki Pajaro, you gotta say, I have to motivate this team.
So go ahead, they give us a super chat, thank you, thank
you.
How do you sound pre-game while pre-gaming?
The virus says, thank you, a super chat, thank you, thank
you.
Is I remember.
Oh, no.
Offside.
Ooh.
Wham.
This looks good.
I'm pre-calling offside.
Offside.
Breath.
Look, he's offside.
He's so offside.
Breath.
All right, we'll try to What's the pork one called?
You don't see it?
That's so offside.
Okay, we're gonna get the...
Ref!
He's playing from the States, Ref!
He's literally...
His link is in America offside!
The pasta.
Yeah, the pasta.
Pastor?
Run faster!
You're so much faster!
You're so old!
Get the boy back in here.
Get the kid.
He's resting up.
I've seen enough.
Get the me-get me-ho back in.
If he's in, he's in the parking lot.
Some- some to get back in.
I've seen enough.
Horrible.
Yeah,
I got I'll pass.
Pastor.
It's past his bedtime, Toki.
I'll say when it's past your bedtime, miho.
One attempt at the goal three from Ecuador.
That's crazy.
It's been three since 30 minutes ago.
I swear, right?
It's been three since, like, or since when it was, like, at
the 30-minute mark.
Oh, that's it.
That's it.
It's set free perfectly.
Don't hesitate.
Oh, my God.
Bro, why?
There was, like, no one there, bro.
And they hesitated, though.
Yeah, I say there's no angle.
He literally hesitated.
Oh, this is good.
This is a good.
That's taco.
I should have ordered more tacos Two was definitely not
enough.
I just didn't know how hungry I was gonna be.
I just didn't know how hungry I was gonna be all this spicy
Oh, it's spicy.
I mixed both of them, but it's spicy
Oh my that was a thousand saints that was an insane
That was a good save though.
I I had it to the goal like look at that shot.
Oh my like like his hat like it's such a hard hit that it
literally like there was a momentum like that was very
physics where he had to stop it which is a better sauce
greener in the red one
oh that was close that was close yeah i should have got
three i forgot the the the magic taco number oh this was
spicy you lose a use oh oh that's a little zing it has a
zing to it
they're both spicy
oh that's gonna be me soon i'm gonna be in that seltzer soon
hydration break at six seven all right hey hey oh there is
all right i'm gonna put the i'm gonna get the carne asada
carne asada now
all right put in the green sauce i'm gonna try green sauce
first
I'm pretty sure I'm definitely sure that the chefs were
definitely watching the game I don't think a chef I
definitely think maybe the chefs were watching the game
because I don't think two tacos would take an hour
I'm pretty sure two tacos would not hang in the house.
Hey, dude.
Pass the taco.
Oh, that was good.
I should have ordered more tacos.
That was really fucking good.
I'll show you guys what it looks like, too.
But...
I'm just gonna get the rest of that meat that fell out of my
taco.
No!
You're not getting that.
This is spicy, Dad.
This is spicy.
You can't have this.
He wants me to drop some spice into it.
Oh!
Get him back in.
Get him back in!
That time's over, kid!
We saw what happened when you were out.
That was not a fucking pass.
Get the child in.
I demand the child to play and keep playing.
Bring back Miho.
Miho, remember who picked you up after football practice,
Miho?
You know how you're going to go take a break?
You know who pays for your lessons, Miho?
Who bought you that ball?
his mom you mean his mom yeah but who picked it up who
picked up the ball for him
his mom yes but who who drove his mom oh nice save nice d
nice d
that's a crazy save Remember who invested in you, invested
in you, Miho.
Yes, but who told his mom where to get the bar?
Nice!
Good!
He's just like, he's okay.
No, he's not!
Ref!
Head trauma!
Red card!
You see it?
His head touched the pole, Rev.
His head touched the pole.
It definitely touched the pole, Rev.
Rev, look what I'll say.
And the scissors, six corotas.
Red card.
The pole!
The pole is from Ecuador.
Red card.
That's an Ecuador paw
Nice Nice header Hey No He was eating some good Chorikezo
right now Don't come in
Wait no Ah Yes, that's right.
Yes.
Live with your guilt.
Live with the mist that you had.
Live with it.
That's right.
Let it eat you up that you didn't make that shot.
And then you play worse.
Yes.
It was there for you perfectly.
But you missed.
Let it roll up inside you and make you play even worse.
Yes.
your country yeah come on give them a break guys guys no
hard feelings no hard feelings guys it's no hard feelings
guys no hard it's just a football it's just soccer so keep
please it's just a boy Oh, no.
Hey, guys, guys.
Tio's just joking.
Guys, Tio's just joking, everybody.
Not even your team.
Guys, we never get to experience this during the Canada
versus South Africa game.
90% of that game was just passes.
Wait, why are we having no goalie?
What happened to our goalie?
what what happened to our goalkeeper he where did he go did
they injure him they got him red card red card now it's
personal oh no that's bad wait that's actually pretty bad
that's not our starter goalkeeper It's okay, if we get third
goal, it wouldn't matter.
Oh, no.
This is pretty bad for us.
It was vaporized.
Oh, my God.
This is a pure head.
No, no.
It's because we swapped goalies.
Oh, oh, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
What happened?
Yes.
What does he do?
Oh, my God.
Did you not?
see that he literally shanked his sides good call ref good
call i agree i saw that knife shank it was like it was like
the speed of light you know he did a little and then that's
why he fell guys that's
you see that play that at 0.2 speed and then you'll see the
knife come out that's why he tripped that's so true
He had a He didn't He shanked the size I know you have to do
A 0.25 speed
Alright Yeah try and play more Haramba bro Yeah fucking play
more Haramba See what it got you bro See what got you play
like a little Bitch Ecuador, no hard feelings, Ecuador, no
hard feelings, Ecuador.
If it, if, I, I, I will say, I will say, if I was in that
restaurant, and if, if everybody there was from Ecuador, it
was, and they gave, made me an honorary, honorary Ecuador,
Ecuadorian.
the other side it was just right time right place right time
right place would have been a different in an alternate
universe i would have been cheering for ecuador it feels
just being tia We claimed your first...
You are Mexican now.
It's in your blood.
You can never forget your roots.
Are they replaced them?
Oh, that's BM.
That's...
What?
They replaced both their starters.
They're like...
I swear, Mexico...
Bro, you should have done it the last...
Yeah, they're on balling now.
No!
Mexico, don't do it!
Don't become the villain!
No!
We can never escape her on ball.
Don't do it, Mexico!
You don't need Haram ball.
You don't need it.
You're better than this.
Mexico down.
This is the coach's fault.
This is the, oh, what?
They need the rest.
We can never escape.
Park the bus.
Build the wall.
It's time for Mexico to build the wall Not the wall It's a
hard turn Yes No
Next time Remember the prime toe keepers Saloo Golden thank
you with Super Chat Thank you
all right
uno reversal this is bad though oh no yes nice headie oh
shit but it went back to Ecuador yeah nice catch take your
time take your time guys guys take your time you can stall
as long as you want you can be like who do I who do I give
this to oh no I know this is remember this is meta we play
meta now guys no this is meta we gotta go with the meta
there's like going ghost during overtime please guys it's my
rank-up game please guys go ahead and thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you oh they made a roll against
patched it?
When did they patch this?
No!
They patched it!
Which patch notes, guys?
Which patch notes?
What was that?
Oh, no.
Oh, nice save!
Live hot fixing.
Literally before this World Cup.
Wait, who got hurt?
Yeah, that's it.
Wait, whose fault is it?
I...
Oh, my God.
Slap.
All right, nice.
Because I couldn't tell because the other Mexican player
like pushed him a little too.
So I don't know which is the right of way.
That guy jumped so high though.
That's a crush.
Take your time Milk that time as long as you want
He touched it Yes!
Wait, what?
I was looking at the coach The coach was like, that's our
ball You know?
You see that?
It was like the coach I thought the coach was the ref for a
second He was like, yeah, it's our side I was like, yeah!
Oh no.
Oh.
Nice!
Nice head!
someone please check on these guys later on it's been
heading way too much someone please oh ref yes yes ref he
hit his head too ref he slapped in the back of his head look
at the replay look look at that oh see that his hand touched
his head right there i know it's so fast he has like you
have to zero zero point two five the speed and then you'll
see it and then ref he slapped him in his head ref and then
he kicked him in the balls give him a red card
0.25 speed it ref look at that 0.25 he also had a gun
guys you you you can't you can't you barely see in the naked
eye because you know they're pro You know, so they go,
they're so fast.
But luckily, I have very fast eyes.
So I was able to, oh, nice head.
Oh, nice.
He also pulled out a chair, ref.
0.1 time that speed.
I saw it.
Ref, he stole his nose.
I got your nose.
Is there any plus minutes?
There should be, right?
I don't know.
Like, they've been...
They've been...
fucking around with the time a lot.
Oh, my God.
Ecuador really won in the score.
You can tell when...
Oh!
You can tell when Mexico won it started haram-balling.
It went like, we got two.
We got our two.
I like the pink shoes.
They're really pretty.
I've already...
The Canada vs.
Switzerland game, everyone had the orange pink shoes.
Except for one guy.
And it was so noticeable.
Like, literally one guy on Team Canada just didn't have the
orange.
What the fuck, bro?
You could...
What the fuck?
Bro, did you not catch that, bro?
Yeah.
Bro, bro, how do you just, he's like, I don't need to get
that, bro.
Like, whoops.
Guys, it was min-maxing waste time wasting.
Yeah, he's just like, guys, guess it's okay.
I'm just wasting time.
Oh.
Nice.
Oh, but it's a corner kick.
That's not good.
Oh, wait, no, it's a free ball.
It's a three-throw.
At least it's not a corner ball.
A corner kick.
He's just a raw maxing.
Oh.
Try to reset.
Oh, no.
That's a good reset.
Nice.
What's that?
Oh, no.
What's that pass, bro?
Oh, they're resetting.
They're doing a full reset right now.
That's not good.
oh nice nice the physics not nice we need we need oh nice
there's a nice okay i was like quick get the subs in i get
have the subs start standing in front of them get them in we
need more people over there have the tire rod get the coach
to stand in the goal too two more minutes i don't know how
as the extra extra time though oh the possession like i need
mexico to like possess the ball a lot more oh oh gosh oh re
oh this is scary oh nice nice nice but they're oh they're
resetting way too they're letting them reset way too much
they're playing i know they have to play super defensively
but it's so scary because they're like they're you know
they're there for so long
They're just, they're giving them too many opportunities,
which is very scary.
Like, nice.
Good, good.
Full reset, full reset.
Why?
Just, oh my, there was just one guy.
It was literally, bring me home back.
Bring him back.
I've seen enough.
I've fucking seen enough.
I don't know.
Bro got so scared.
Yeah, the pass was fumbled and he was too scared.
Oh, there's the rough cab.
The fucking rough cab.
He should have just taken the shot.
It doesn't matter.
He should have just fucking taken the shot.
He got way too fucking scared for no reason.
It was literally a 1v1 and he choked.
Is it over?
Seven minutes?
Are you serious?
minutes eight seven minutes what were you doing using the
bath half the players have to have a bathroom break
bro bro okay yeah yeah nice nice he's like oh i'm just oh
let me just oh just slowly grab the ball we have seven
minutes anyway like prodigal kids it's like oh let me just
Little guy.
A few time wasting.
Now that's a wrong ball.
And then...
Again, min-maxing.
And the ball's been through so much.
Guys, guys, pause.
I gotta cuddle the ball up and give it a good night kiss.
Ecuador has been like, oh, that's a, that's a really good
pass.
Oh, oh, that was bad.
That was so close.
That was actually so close.
It was just a little bit.
That was so close.
I knew it wasn't going to hit, though.
It was just, I literally needed just a little bit, just a
little bit more.
Bro, I have to sift through.
just a little too high yeah oh
get it get it get it get it get it what the oh that's a nice
fake that was a real oh ref yes yes yes ref he kicked him in
the balls red
his entire leg body and torso was in front of him yes yes
yeah bye Kendry Yes, yes, take your time.
Take your time.
Revi, he took his lunch money.
Rodrigo, they give a super chat.
Thank you.
All right, dad.
Why are you barking?
Hey, hey.
No.
I'm back.
Okay.
Former.
What's going on?
I walked away for for five seconds what's going on wait what
what happened the clock is still running don't guys come on
oh he covered his mouth
is that bad way why why is covering the mouth You can't
block your mouth!
Teacher, he covered his mouth!
Teacher!
He covered his mouth, teacher!
You can't...
Yes!
He caught her!
Yeah, I was just like, they cover mouths to say, yeah, I
love how he's like, teacher, teacher, professor, he said a
bad word.
He alts it, bro, man alts it.
Look what he did.
Get him the fuck out of here, bro.
You high five, the racist, bro.
Bro, his teammates are like, nice track, nice alt.
He doesn't care, bro.
That, bro, it's fucking...
The team was just like, nice out, bro.
The time, bro, I had to use this up before the game ends.
I'm not...
But it's like, GG's open mic to...
joins voice chat.
The man fucking last two minutes.
Oh, joins VC.
I gotta take one before we
send you a friend request after the match.
Says one thing then leaves Gabe.
That's like Crazy.
Yeah, be brave and say it.
I love the red card at the top left.
Oh.
10 seconds.
10.
Oh, it's getting louder.
Mekiko's getting louder.
I'm sorry, Ecuador.
I'm sorry.
Oh, Dirty is almost...
They're getting desperate.
wait there's no no loss prevention that's it the whistle
should go off the whistle should go off any moment now I
guess with the red card though
where is it where's the full-time whistle I was like make
the call ref
guys it's not too late to do another alt guys it's not it's
not Not too late!
There's still time!
Oh, plus two.
Two more minutes.
One more minute.
Press...
Yellow card!
Collect all the cards.
Gotta catch them all.
Another card!
Bro, cover that map, bro!
Oh shit!
Okay!
They're so...
Jump in the VC.
I'm just...
They're just like...
I'm just gonna take them down with me at this point before
their next game.
Like, that's crazy.
This is it!
Two!
Mexico never lost a game on home turf
It's never lost a game Gee, look at that Every time I've
done a watch a line We've won The team I cheer for wins Viva
Mexico Mexico Two Oh Look at that We won
On to the favorite fifth game.
Mike, thank you.
Thank you.
The super chat.
Marco, thank you.
Thank you.
Viva Mexico.
We just need the United States to win And then we can
complete the cum trifecta
That's all we need, guys That's all we need We have Canada
We have Mexico We just need the U.S.
to join us
Long live,
Mexico.
Vamos, mi ho, vamos, Mexico.
Thank you.
Thank you, the Super Chat, July.
Thank you, thank you.
Wes, thank you, the Super Chat, thank you.
Thank you.
Ecuador tried collecting Exodia late to win the game with
those cards.
Thank you for the Super Chat, thank you.
Thank you.
I actually want to know, like, how many cards did Ecuador
got?
I feel like every...
Every 10 minutes was a new card for Ecuador.
Come home, U.S.
Come home.
Without you, we're just CM slash MC.
It doesn't have the same ring to it.
U.S.
It's like the all-mite meme where he points at U.S.
You're next.
Yeah.
You're next, US.
You have to complete the trifecta.
We all have to be there.
All three of the host countries.
If no, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Viva Mexico.
Carons.
Gracias, doki.
Produce.
Menisión.
It was super chat.
Thank you.
Napaja.
That.
Was no problem again.
In Spanish.
So y'all, thank you.
Thank you.
Demokratia, mi qui, 특ana.
Yaya, ex, mexicana Thing of the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you , thank you.
You might say you complete me.
Think of the super chat, papa smurf.
Thank you, thank.
Donata.
No problem.
What can I say?
All in a day's work, Mexico.
As your honorary Mexican, I'm here for you.
Potato, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for cheering us, Tito Toki.
Your commentary made it all better.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't have to be salsa, guys.
Isn't that great?
I get to live another day.
No salsa for Doki.
I think it was Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
El Tigre.
Viva Mexicano.
Doki, Hamanah.
Yes, Mexicana.
Doki, good luck, chat, for Mexicana.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, Tigre.
Thank you, thank you.
Wasn't when I last watched a Mexican...
When it was funny, when I came back from the
Canada-Switzerland game, and then we pulled up watching the
game, and then we scored while I was watching.
It was like 0-0, right?
And then, like, I was like, oh, the Mexico game is still
going on.
And I pulled, and then we pulled up the stream, and then
they got a goal.
I don't know, coincidence?
I don't know.
I don't want to say it's a coincidence, but it's funny that
that happened twice.
It's weird that that happened twice in a row.
Shout out to the homegirl.
Doki, Carlos, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Jamie, thank you for the super chat.
Doki is pleased to be a true Latina.
You have to say gracias.
What does that mean?
Fernand, all right, thank you, super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, something Latino America.
words are oh what a game that was a really good game though
I will say I well that was a really intense game except for
the last half the last half I'm sorry but I I just don't
like Harambo the first step was fucking intense with all the
passes were insane the crosses were beautiful um the shots
were like it wasn't like a it wasn't like a pussy shot you
know like like the kick was like you know like the like love
taps or whatever it was an actual shot shot you know like an
actual kick so it's like the first half was such a good good
game last half last half i will say they play with my heart
a little bit yeah the last half was like Yeah Like Mexico
won Mexico won So people are saying We broke the curse Have
you guys haven't been past top 16 Like have you guys not
made it to top 16 in a while What do they mean by breaking
the curse
Chris thank you for the super chat They can think oh yeah
Canada day is in Three hours
In 40 years in the last 40 oh my god that's crazy we're all
making world records here me canada mexico we're the same
well now for us it's our first time ever past group stages
but we're the same
guys we're the same we're the same canada we're not so
different after all guys the course is broken ash i think it
was super chat they could thank you we must giving her pesos
we need her annabar on the side for the rest of the also i
finally opened a tamara and it's good they're literally the
same this world cup is crazy a lot of like the strongest
teams already knocked out nobody would have expected dana to
be up there the fact that to be fair we had a easier
knockout stage we definitely had an easier knockout stage
but hey we're here and the Netherlands aren't sorry sorry
that's a low boss like what the fuck did I Netherlands is
like the fuck did I do sorry I just picked a random country
that didn't make it in yet I don't know don't worry
Netherlands we're fighting we're fighting Morocco next
The fact that Canada is in, and Japan, Netherlands, and
Germany, and Sweden are out.
That's crazy.
I don't think anybody, if you ask a Canadian, if you ask a
Canadian a year ago if this was ever going to happen, the
Canadian would go to Polymarket right now and bet it all and
go all in.
That's insane.
Canada's in and all.
all like all the other countries the giants are all falling
that's right oh man the future is now canada's on the upside
invest in canada and mexico
oh god i think it was super chat thank you thank you brisby
thank you super chat thank you thank you gracias doki love
your comment thank you i'm glad you guys enjoyed my
commentary i got I might be a little toxic, guys.
Let's see.
Saks, thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Most of them say that Mexico has not conceded a single goal
so far in this world.
That's crazy.
The defense is insane.
The goalkeeper is insane.
I'll say.
Kusa, thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, the honor in Latina.
Thank you for supporting Mexico and having a stream of it.
Oh, you'll stream more World Cup matches like Colombia
match.
I might actually watch the Colombia match.
Well, not the one against...
Ghana right I'm not gonna watch I'm not I don't know if I'll
stream I think like the one to watch on the one I don't know
which one I will do next um uh my schedule is sort of all
over the place right now because I'm trying to figure out
like what to do like especially for I know what to do for my
birthday but like birthday is gonna be more of a hangout
because the actual real birthday stream might have to be
when I come back from LA uh because I don't trust holy shit
look at that guy run oh my god that reep that guy is oh my
god that beautiful shot beautiful goal there sorry they're
doing the replay right now yeah that that's that's actually
see that's what i mean that guy didn't hesitate he like time
he didn't hesitate and that's why i was just like when like
there was so much hesitation like at in the second half but
during the first step that guy fucking yolo did he was just
like fuck that share i'm going straight in
now the she king thank you super chat thank you thank you
taco fun for dad for celebration thank you super chat thank
you thank you no thank you i think it was super chat thank
you thank you and we get the meme cup of mexico versus
portugal also be really fun in the final is cape verita
versus austria i think it was super chat thank you why would
it be funny banana i think it was super chat thank you thank
you and the subson said We were going to the finals
against...
Oh, I saw that.
I think it was Super Chat.
Thank you.
Angel, I think it was Super Chat.
That was a good game, though.
First half was a good game.
Second half was just...
I think the funniest thing about the second half was
literally just...
The guy alting.
When my man decided to rip the alt...
Join FEC and started alting.
I think I don't know why it was funnier the the alt itself
or the fact that like um the Mexican player was like
professor professor he said a bad word
funny it like if you let you look at the replay it was so
fucking funny like he was like like like teacher yeah
Yeah It was just a bad word He said a really bad word Thank
you Super Chat Thank you Thank you That was so fucking funny
Um I was sitting They gave a super chat Thank you My
favorite part is when they kicked the ball that one time And
then that other time Oh like the What was it The Brazil
versus Japan game Where Brazil fucking Alt did like Um Did
like friendly fire on his own team made that I saw that gift
that was so funny oh my god when Brazil just he's just like
fuck you in particular you guys didn't see the gift wait let
me wash my hands and I'll show you the gift guys um also I
need you guys help for something else too um there's people
for going to the concert but let me wash my hands and then
oh i forgot my churros oh okay whatever i still want to wash
my hands i'll be right back
i'm back oh all right let me blow my nose real quick uh prof
they give a super chat thank you thank you as agree here's
the poem even the style is a big balance couldn't stand up
to dokey bear sharpshooter skills after such a great game
commentary more love to give We shall.
Viva Mexico.
Thank you.
Super chat, proud.
Papa.
Thank you, super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm going to guys enjoy my commentary.
I've been commentating like, you know, World Cup games
before.
So I just joloted it.
I just said everything that was in my head.
Like, I just started shooting.
The Canada game was the first time I did, like, World Cup
commentary.
So I'm glad you guys enjoyed it.
I think it just helps that I used to play soccer.
I think, like, football, it helps.
helps a lot so I know like the general gist of things and
then like I like when during the after the um uh Canada
versus South Africa game um my algorithm was all about
Harambaugh and I was like that's what it's called fucking
Harambaugh I was like fuck this meta someone patch it out
Yeah.
Yep.
It's like, fuck this meta, bro.
Like.
All right.
Guys, it's ad time.
So, guys.
Guys, I have a concert in LA on July 4th, guys.
But for those who can't make it, I do have streaming
tickets.
I did say we're going to have my ad.
It's ad time.
time.
So you guys want to support me as well.
You can watch this really cool 3D concert that's going to
happen on July 4th.
It's super cool.
Look at the guest lineup.
It's going to be Me, Chibi-Doki, Shachi, Doobie, Mimi,
Amali, Mint, Lamo, and Snuffy.
Yeah!
And you can watch it.
You can buy a streaming ticket right now.
Right, let me...
Right here.
Right now.
Yeah, see?
Your Tio can sing.
We really mean a lot to come check it.
We'll also have a, for those who don't know, we'll also
have, we'll have three songs streamed for free on this
channel.
So I might, also, by the way, there might be a song where I
say a little bit of Español.
All I'm saying is that Maybe, maybe there might be a song
where I sing a little bit of Espanol with Cheeby Doki.
So you might better check it out.
It's not in the free portion.
So you might have to buy a streaming ticket, guys.
And a lot of songs are going to be from the 2000s to 2010
era.
it's gonna be really really fun it's like less than a week
guys it's gonna it's less than a week till the concert so
please really mean a lot for to support me and chibidoki and
sachi duvini amalini mint limu and snappy yeah so please get
the streaming ticket guys yippee
CEO.
All right, add over.
All right.
That's another thing.
Okay, so I just say where are they playing right now?
Oh, I got the alt.
Oh, my God.
I came back just in time for him to alt him.
I swapped back to the feed.
I swapped back to the feed and then it's him alting.
Could you Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Doki, probably.
You met me at a very Latina time in my life.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
July, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, perfect time.
I literally swapped back to the replay, to the live feed,
and it was literally him alting.
At 0.5 speed.
I'm gonna be Mexico, Papi.
You see, you see?
I'm gonna super chat, thank you, thank you.
Bernard, I think I'm gonna super chat, thank you, thank you.
Bro got banned for the talk.
Bro got banned live.
Oh, yeah, Casamiro indeed tackled his own teammate.
It was Faketa.
Now he's out of the World Cup, not just because of that.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Adira, for my favorite Gino mate.
I'll watch all the matches with you.
Tomato plushie went.
We had a tomato plushie.
But I want to make a small version in the future, though.
So in the future, definitely.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Kitsune, I need to thank you.
It was a YouTube plush, but it's gone now.
Some lucky dragons were able to grab a tomato plushie.
I want to make a tiny one in the future.
I think that'll be fun.
We'll have a miniature tomato plushie.
It was a croaky one, too.
It was like croaky, alt girl, and tomato.
All right.
What was I?
All right, guys.
So, this is another thing.
Let's see.
Let me play.
It's time.
We got to play our song.
wait guys wait actually maybe I can uh let's see all right
let me grab you guys want something I need to find a Mexican
song that is copyright free copyright free let's see I can
find some
work guys all right guys this is okay it's copyright free i
could soon i thank you with a super chat thank you thank you
thank you super chat thank you thank you i have the tomato
croaky alt dokey and classic dokey flushes they're very good
they use super chat thank you thank you bump bump it says it
says uh copyright free
you're in a very Latino time in my life right now all right
so for those who are going to the concert they are letting
me name three alcoholic drinks three cocktails for the
concert and need your guys's help on what what to name them
we don't know what they're gonna look like we don't know
what they're gonna look like We don't know how, what kind of
alcohol it's going to be in it.
But we get to name three drinks, guys.
So I'm trying to help me figure out.
We're not, guys, I'm giving you guys the power to name a
drink.
It's like name one for dokeytail.
Mexican dokey.
Should we do that?
We should have one called.
Honorary Mexican.
Wait, what if we just name one honorary Mexican?
Like, I'm not naming one gum.
What if the U.S.
doesn't drink the teal drink?
All right.
What do we do?
All right, honorary Mexican.
Okay, one of them will be Mexican themed.
Okay, we'll have one of them be Mexican themed.
Okay, we're not naming all of them.
Oh, I like croquetteini.
That's a good one.
Let me write that down.
croquetini I like that Croquetini do we do honorary Mexican
honorary Mexican or the Mexican dokey fermented no we're not
doing that thank you thank you uh but probably birthday give
us super chat they had tokyla oh dokyla wait i like that
dokyla all right so we have i'm gonna get a lot of options
in all right we have crookitini the honorary mexican
dokyla dokyla is good that's a good one Oh, wait, there was
another one that I wrote down.
What did I wrote down?
Oh, I didn't write it down.
God damn, I forgot to write it down.
I forgot.
I'm not naming it gum.
Oh, the dad hadn't.
Wait, I like that.
Dad hadn't.
All right.
I'm not writing gum.
oh the sloppy sister wait all right the sloppy sister all
right i wonder if i just put it in the okay name all right
it's only naming um i'll just give them a list and they'll
pick from it
that's me related to us okay i'm a dragoon name give me a
dragoon name guys What if we what if it a cocktail with
alcoholic drink was named after you guys?
What would it be?
What would it be guys?
I'm about to Guys, it was a dragoon drink goon juice the
gooner Drag okay, the dragoon.
Okay, do we get goon juice?
Do we I actually like goon juice?
All right, wait, all right, if I have to pick I'm Have to
goon juice.
Goon juice.
Honor the honorary Mexican.
And the sloppy sister.
How about that?
Do we do sloppy sister or the sloppy sister?
Do we do the sloppy sister or sloppy sister?
Not that.
But why is this?
Okay.
All right, I'll let them know.
Did I not confirm this?
Okay, let's see.
Uh...
Oh, my gosh.
I need to confirm something.
Uh, yes, everything looks good.
Yes, that's okay.
Also, here...
Oh, wait.
I need to type it.
I almost typed it.
Okay, here are the drink names.
All right, here it is.
I don't know.
who to at for this there you go all right so we had three
drinks named for the concert for those who are going to the
concert goon juice the honorary mexican and the sloppy
sister what these sloppy sisters you wanted sisters to be
plural or uh i have the sloppy sister Captain, thank you for
the super chat, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you,
you, thank you, thank you, thank the sloppy sisters, please,
or can I get the sloppy sisters, please, or can I get the
sloppy sister, please,
Singular?
All right.
When you're there, when you're there, remember to post it on
the hashtag Doki Rewind Time.
Which drink you got?
Let me know if you got the Goon Juice, the Honorary Mexican,
or the Sloppy Sister.
Yeah.
I'll have a Sloppy Sister, please.
I'll have the Sloppy Sister, please.
All right, task, job done.
I did my job.
Can I get four?
Can I get four of the sloppy sister, please?
Oh, I got to get four.
If you're ordering the sloppy sister, remember to order
four, guys.
Can I have the goon juice?
I look forward to seeing you guys all at concert.
I'll put it.
here i look forward to seeing all of you guys there it's
gonna be super i can't believe less than a week i have the
i'm flying out very soon too oh my god yeah please support
this please support uh the concert guys um uh francis thank
you super chat thank you to me too i'm super excited and
thank you for helping me pick the postcard it really does
help a lot because i was like um i I had to decide it now,
like, which one again.
I was like, I decided on stream, you know?
I was like, ah, fuck, okay, I decided on stream.
Wait, Gully didn't say, what did you think of my outfit?
What did you think about my outfit?
Can I call, wait, let's call Gully.
I won't call, wait, can I call you on stream?
Let's call Gully.
What does he think about my outfit?
I'm feeling a little Mexican today.
Oh, I forgot to show you guys a picture of my food.
Let me show you guys.
Let's see.
I don't know if he can...
I don't want to like...
They're playing the aisle right now.
So, unfortunately, I can't join them.
Because I have to go...
I have to call Matara right after.
I can't join.
I can't join out of the commentar right after the stream.
Wait, let me show my food first.
Yes, I want to show you guys my food.
All right, let me show you the food I got.
It was good.
taco okay let me make sure there's no reflections yeah
there's no reflections we're good but but but but but but
Matara hey Matara I'm making oh yeah I told them I said I
was like do I should I pre-game before it's telling them
about look there's my food that's a good ass taco that was
really good though yeah so sorry sorry Ecuador you lost so I
can cover you I no I didn't I didn't pre-game yet Matara I'm
just I'm I'm just embodying the spirit of my inner teal
right now
I'm just my inner teal It's just running wild.
Yeah, that's what I say.
I should have got another taco.
But I had the Churikazo.
So, like, oh, I forgot I have my churros.
Now, that's a taco.
Yeah.
It's not long ago.
You have cups with all the sloppy assistant force people.
Buy four drinks to get all four cups for the collection.
Don't keep failways.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
All right, let me get my churro.
I got Truro's, too.
Yeah!
Alright, I'm gonna call Gully really quick.
I...
Wait, I don't have Discord stuff in there.
Let me grab Discord output.
There we go.
I'll call Gully.
I'm gonna call Gully right now.
Gully!
Yo!
Make it go one!
Yeah!
watching you
gotta revoke your card you gotta stop speaking spanish yeah
yeah i can't believe you didn't watch wow oh wait gully was
muted yep getting goals yeah guys guys sorry they couldn't
hear you but he didn't watch it guys he yeah i didn't watch
it i experienced it it was yeah how did you experience it
dude i was on the edge of my seat yeah refreshing the page
until it went from zero to one yeah and then i refreshed it
again and then it went zero to two and i was like yes yes
you're just watching the stats page bro you're not allowed
to speak spanish anymore I don't speak Spanish I don't like
this force or pee you're doing I've never spoken Spanish a
day in my life that's a fucking lie I've heard you I'm a I'm
a no sabo kid you know what that is
do you know what a no sabo kid is I mean you could be one
too I'm not I'm gonna wait I'm gonna wait until the
tick-tock frag movies come out yeah I get to see all the
highlights yeah
that's how you experience sports in 2020 yeah that's how you
experience you weren't I can't believe it I can't believe I
can't believe I'm more Mexican than you
True unironically true.
You actually watched the soccer game.
I can't believe it's support.
I can't believe you just go.
What's wrong with that?
I'm being a dino right now.
You're ready to be a dino.
You're ready to be a dino to support.
Listen, listen, listen, listen.
They have a strong team.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm not even worried.
I don't even know.
in like 20 minutes there's gonna be like a frag movie with
um by vicente fernandez like oh yeah you heard that you
heard the accent in there you see that again you heard the
what what wait you okay but did you okay yeah the frag movie
of who again oh mexico when they score goals yeah which
which player um
He rolled the shit out of that R, guys.
He rolled the R.
I can't believe him.
Do you like my outfit, Gully?
Let's see.
You like it?
Bro, you got a Caguama?
Okay.
You got the 32 ounce?
Yeah.
I call those the movie beers.
They get you like nice and toasty.
Yeah.
You like my little sombrero too.
My little tiny dragon at the top.
You like that?
I didn't even see that.
I didn't even see the little dragoon.
I saw the sombrero.
Yeah, yeah.
He's up there.
Wait, he has a mustache too.
Yeah, we both have mustaches.
Wait, what's on your plate?
Hold on.
Zoom in.
It's a taco.
Computer.
Computer, enhance.
Enhance.
Hold on, what is that?
I know it's rice, but like, what is that?
I don't know, I found it on Google.
Tacos?
What is that, beans on the side?
I'm okay.
Yeah.
Wait, what are you eating, bro?
You should...
I'm eating a churro right now.
But I got tacos and churros.
Bro, what the fuck kind of churros are you getting in
Canada?
There's no way, like...
Um... They're actually good.
you know there's mexicans living in canada right yeah
they're kind of everywhere they kind of they're the mexicans
in canada so i got churros i got south tacos i got carne
asada and uh pastor taco are you gonna watch every mexico
game i don't know i mean they really want me to watch every
mexico game they think i'm good luck because i am they
literally start like the game got delayed for an hour uh
because i was late for my stream and then god was like stop
the game we gotta wait for her to start stream oh we gotta
wait for for dokeybird yeah we gotta wait for dokeybird
they're like you have to you can't quit now dude yeah who
who scored um the quit quinn quinn quinn oh yeah quinn yeah
that guy i keep That guy's like really fucking good.
Yeah, how good is he?
If he's so good, what's his full name?
Um, Guignan.
And then, uh, Jimenez.
Jimenez was the other guy.
There were some good shots, though.
They're good ass shots.
guys you know what we need the united states to win next so
then so we can complete the come trifecta do you know the
come i think yeah the canada united states mexico yeah yeah
we just need us to win and we're all is canada actually good
no wait why are you why'd you laugh we're better we've
improved no do you know that did you know that world cup did
you last okay okay no okay if you want chat so like i
believe it i believe okay so basically we're the thing is
we've improved this was our first time ever getting to
knockout stage and also the first time we've ever won a game
like this world cup is the first time the world cup has been
around for what a hundred well almost a hundred years right
and then a minute yeah yeah and then This was the, this
World Cup was the first time Canada's ever won a game, like
a singular game.
That's so sad.
Oh my God.
We've improved.
We, if you, okay, but the thing is, if you compare it to
the...
That's actually so devastating.
We're getting better.
That's why we're so happy.
We don't care what happens.
How does Canada have fans?
We don't care what happens in top 16.
We made it at top 16.
What's the, what do Canadians even chant?
Like, oh, Canada.
shot there's just no way i don't even i don't even know i
don't give him no to be fair when i was at the stadium
because i went to actually watched the game physically yeah
there was a lot of words being said it was very hard to hear
to be fair we just like words being said i just couldn't
process it i just kind of dissociated and just stare at the
ball and be like kicked back and forth and then i drank beer
whenever they had a hydration break it was awesome you
didn't watch it it didn't what hydration yeah you're right
i'm just i'm just an alcoholic you're right you're just a
larper i kind of am i'm not gonna lie when it comes to like
soccer and shit oh soccer there it is boom i'm gonna get
flamed i call it soccer okay i interchange it Please excuse
us.
We're North American.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm actually Mexican by association too.
So, like, if it weren't for Doki, I wouldn't even be here.
So, I got, like, I'm like a quarter.
Like, someone cancel.
Take away this quarter blood, like, squeeze it out of him.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Are you going to be dynos with us later or you're I had to
do how long you guys are going to be playing for What time
is it?
It's like 9 43 We should be on for like a few more hours.
All right, because I have to do a recording one hour
recording and then I can hop on for some more dynos
Recording yeah, let's do a recording thing for someone With
one of my friends for her project I'm drinking I also be
coming to the to the dynos I know game drunk, by the way,
so...
Wait, you're drinking?
Yeah, I'm drinking for it.
Did you fucking have her eating churros?
Yeah, eating churros, getting my hard iced tea.
Oh, my God.
What's up?
Vosotros, golly?
Vosotros?
That's...
Wait, Vosotros with a V?
Yeah.
That's like some Spanish shit.
I sent us this man to speak Vosotros.
No, I did not speak.
Thank you.
I do not speak vosotros.
We don't, we don't, we don't like that around here.
Who does, who does that mean?
Bro it's like, it's hard to explain, but like, vosotros is
not a real word and I refuse to acknowledge it.
No, no.
You, no, you are.
No, I just, I'm a knower.
I'm going to know where I just...
You're in nowhere.
Yeah.
A gully nose ball.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Not up in here.
Bro, is your chat just filled with like a bunch of Mexicans
right now?
Yes, I'm on it.
They gave me the pass.
I'm honoring Mexicans.
You type one.
Do you type one of your Mexican?
If you watch the soccer game tonight, you're practically
Mexican.
That we're all on here.
Well, not go except for golly except for golly Yes, yes,
yes, kind of yes Yeah, if you watch this tell my
That's so fucking funny What do you mean?
How's that funny?
Where's the point?
I'm imagining okay if they're all Mexican I'm imagining them
like at their family like living room right they have their
headphones on and they're like they have dokeybird stream
pulled up next to like the mainstream yes because i'm a
great commentator so like they're probably like it's like
what are you doing son i'm just watching my oshi yeah yeah
exactly exactly unlike you refreshing your stats page okay
what's wrong we're refreshing my stats you could experience
it you could experience the shot your lips through it i did
i will later tonight when when the frag movies pop up yeah
yeah yeah yeah when the tick tock shows up yeah yeah all
right ggs gotta go back to your thano game gully yeah i'm
starving right now yeah go fucking eat gully
We're more Mexican than Gully.
If that man was rolling his R's and everything.
But I'm more Mexican than him.
Oh, yeah.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I did that.
I watched it with my parents while listening to my Oshi.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Adios, Gully.
Captain, the name of Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
Can't believe you brought us a Mexican life.
You know, I didn't realize he didn't even watch the game.
He was actually a life.
He literally sent me like Mexican music.
It was like, play this on...
You know what he sent me?
He sent me this.
He sent me this TikTok last night.
And was like, this is you.
He literally said me this.
I was like, this is you right now.
He was playing.
I know.
Look at the video.
It's a good video, to be fair.
That's me.
That's me right now.
Oh my god But I had a great time though I had a great time
watching the game with all of you guys And I hope that you
guys have Had a great time watching the game with me It was
so fun to watch That was actually really good football The
first half was really good football The second half like I
said Um The second half was like not the greatest, but it
was, you know, we got the two goals in.
We got, at least we got the goals in the first half, and
that's all that matters in the end, you know, like, like I
say we as in like, yeah, we.
First half was what made, what made second half worth it was
the alt, though, when he started I'll think that's what made
it worth it though with the with uh, uh, most laughing and
funny tomato But I'll think it was super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, that yeah.
We I was part of it too Um, I am the honorary Mexican.
So, um, I'm part of the we now.
Uh, but other than that I had a great time watching the
games with you guys.
I don't know what other games we have next.
I don't know.
We'll see.
I don't know what's the next watch a lot we're gonna do.
I need to make my schedule for today, by the way.
Sorry for the late schedule.
It was just a lot.
We do have a collab with Mint on the second.
So there is that.
There might not be a stream on the third because, oh, the
stream on the third will be the Sloppy Sisters panel at
Anime Expo on Twitch.
So that's gonna be our stream.
Because I have to prep for to be in LA.
on the i have to prep to be in la too so just letting you
guys know um schedules a little bit all over the place uh
because i will be in la and the real birthday stream like
with all the fun gifts and surprises might have to be the
week next week but we will have uh the con the first three
songs of the concert be streamed up for free uh on my
channel on my birthday and i'll do a post concert stream
post concert birthday stream where we just hang out and talk
so there won't be Anything like big surprises or anything
Maybe maybe a video Maybe a video will be uploaded Or
something but Just letting you guys know in advance Because
I don't want to like have like a big Big thing reveal or
anything While I don't have my setup When I'm on my laptop
Yeah I don't want to I don't want to do it when I'm on my
laptop Because I don't even know like how Good the
connection's going to be when I'm There so So I don't want
to, I don't want to risk it, you know?
Anyway, anyway, before I'm going, before I go, because like
I said, I have to, oh my God, I've been streaming for four
hours, Jay.
Like, before I go, concert is in.
One, two, four days, guys.
Four days.
Check out the tickets, the streaming tickets.
So you can watch the concert too live with us if you can't
make it.
Hey, guys, thank you all for coming.
watching the games with me I had a great time watching was
my first World Cup there was not my first but this is my
second time doing a World Cup watch along doing a sports
watch along so I'm glad you've been enjoying the ride and
enjoying the streams and letting me be your honorary Mexican
for the day I really appreciate it guys I'm glad you've been
you've been liking my commentary my very not my apologies
Ecuador but like if I had met a nice Ecuadorian old mature
lady and she had dubbed me an honorary Ecuadorian I would
have been cheering for you guys instead but the Mexicans got
me first I'm sorry I they they adopted me first Ecuador I'm
sorry
So, um, thank you all for letting me be your honoring
Mexican for the day, my fellow Mexicans.
I had a great time cheering for your team, and you guys
played some good-ass football.
Anyways, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture
checked, get up, and move around to get that blood flowing.
You stay up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
Adios, mijo.